To be clear, the original Kiwi Farms
twister has literally no relation to
Quimman. Absolutely zero mention of
Quean. Willie is just lying. Destiny
acts like he hasn't partly built his
career off of having a dedicated
clippers and Twitter and Reddit accounts
dedicated to posting them. Something
many comic creators do not is which he'd
eventually weaponized against its
detractors. Destiny has admitted to
having spies in other communities and
active doers he's also weaponized that
are in his community to further his
campaign of intimidation narrative
control against victims and those
attempting to hold him accountable.
Okay, fence smoker, you're [__] The
sex registry isn't for [__] just
pedophiles or just rape, you [__]
[__] I just Google, [__]
Google. In many places, sharing or
threatening threatening to share revenge
porn uh is a criminal offense. And in
some uh jurisdictions, a conviction can
require uh require you to register as a
sex offender. Um, she's that quote it
that she's reading there. That's what
just
[Music]
All right. There's like there's dude,
there's some tweets I want to look at
before I get into the debate review or
whatever. Right. Love watching the uh
the Despacito commentary [__] mauled
after the Willie Mac Show video dropped.
The whole but Destiny thing is [__]
obsessive fan behavior to try to deflect
from their own unhinged actions. We all
know JTOK, Queman, and Bad Empanada are
[__]
Uh again, putting Jay-to and Quean next
to bad empanada is very bad faith. There
is no evidence that any of these people
support doxing, endorse doxing, or allow
doxing. Doxers are banned from their
community. Uh these people openly
denounce doxing. Whereas people like Bad
Empanada and people like Destiny openly
praise doxing. The whole but Destiny
thing is [__] It's not [__]
because Destiny is conf, you know,
accusing these communities of doxing
when they haven't done it. So, it's
like, but Destiny, you're the one that's
doing this, right? It's it's very
[__] And of course, it's very silly
that Mantis is saying this. Um, if DGG
wants to be taken seriously at all. I
mean, again, it's like a [__] cult at
this point, so it's not like it's not
like they're going to see a [__]
Mantis tweet being dishonest and it's
going to change their minds. Nobody's
going to give a [__] Um, but it's just
really [__] seeing like this
obviously DGER, you know, person who's
like e- dating tom foolery person who's
been [__] over constantly.
Uh, and they're still defending this
[__] It's like, okay, what are we
doing? This is [__] And then I see
Queen made an official response. Can I
uh can I go to X cancel
just to make it look better?
All right.
Uh, so Auggie replies to it, but I guess
I guess
let's watch the response first,
I suppose.
Whoa.
Hold on.
We got to We got to change something
here.
Delete this. Paste it.
Slide you over here.
Sorry, folks. So, this is horrific
stuff. This is hor Okay, there we go.
All right, let's watch a bit of this.
It's like 15 minutes. We'll watch this
and then I Well, we I want to watch a
debate about yo
because I've been told that it's epic.
I've been told that it's epic and I want
to watch it. So, we'll watch that after
this. Okay.
If it'll load on X Castle, we might have
to go back. We might have to go back.
This is not looking good.
Let's click on the tweet itself. Maybe
for those who don't know, Willie Mac
released a video last night. It's a
video mainly about bad empanada and bad
empanada doxing Willy Mac's wedding. Now
Willie claims bad empanada is not the
one who doxed his wedding. I take
slightly different definition of dox. My
position of doxing any instance of
someone publishing a collection of piece
of personal identifying information that
is obscured from the public generally or
isn't directly linked to the content
creator for the purposes of harassment.
Uh the only part I disagree with is like
the purposes of harassment. I think this
is generally a fine definition. The the
[__] thing about doxing I feel like
we need to come to like a a [__] a
commutal definition because I feel like
everyone has like a slightly different
definition. I don't think it has to be
for the purposes of doxing, right? Like
if I just reveal someone's address, uh,
and like let's say their address is
literally like 123 Buttad Street or some
[__] right? And I reveal I'm like,
"Dude, this guy lives, this guy, this is
a funny address, right?" And like I
obviously this is an absurd
hypothetical, whatever. It's gay and
[__] but like obviously the
intention there is not to harass, right?
Maybe there's some implicit there, but
like whatever. Um, the intention there
isn't to harass. It's like, "Look at
this guy's funny address name." It's
like, okay, I would still consider that
doxing, right? I would say any revealing
of of information that someone does not
want tied to their online account,
right? Whether it be first name, last
name, face, address, job, friends and
family, stuff like that, right?
That would be poorly argued to be
harassment. I mean, yeah, I again it's
like a hypothetical. I think most people
would agree that that's doxing. I think
doxing is just like revealing of the
private information, right? Um, like
even even in Willy's case, Willie Mac's
name was public before this, right?
Literally all you had to do to find his
wedding [__] was Google his name. You
googled his name and the wedding thing
would pop up. Most people would still
consider that doxing though. Not because
it's like, you know, hidden information,
but because Willie obviously would not
want something like that um being tied
to it.
So my belly is so full from the yummy
morent lately. Then do show some
appreciation, [__] All right,
we need some Oilers in chat so I can do
this every single day and then quit my
job and then sustain myself purely on
Door Dash uh McDonald's orders I think
is what we need. So like sub dono folks
if you want more of this. Okay.
Um but yeah, like I would define that as
doxing even though it's like technically
public, right?
So like yeah, any any revealing of like
personal information I think is just
doxing. Um, I think that's a fine
definition to have. I think getting into
semantics about it is uh kind of
reductive and meaningless and kind of
[__] Um, if someone reveals some
private information about you that is
not tied to your online presence, I
think that's doxing. I think most people
would agree that that's doxing,
you know, whatever. Um, I think it gets
a little more, I guess, confusing. Like
let's say if you have two YouTube
channels, one of them's first last name
and then another one is like XD Gamer or
some [__] like [__] XX
Shadowwarrior_XX,
you know, and then someone ties that IRL
YouTube channel which has your face,
maybe your family in it to your your you
know your like parody channel or
whatever. I think like it gets a little
confusing like is that doxing? Like I
don't know, right? But generally
speaking, uh, tying non internet related
stuff to internet related stuff, I would
describe as doxing.
That's just me. Everybody has like a
slightly different definition.
But yeah, no, this is a fine definition.
I'm not saying that this is a bad
definition. This is fine.
I just don't think it needs to be for
the purposes of harassment. I I I mean,
then again, I struggle to I struggle to
think of an example, right? I struggle
to think of an example uh where
I guess you would dock someone for
without the purposes of harassment. So
maybe this is fine. Whatever. Sure. Now
that is what bad empanada did 100% that
is what he did. Now did he originate the
dogs? No.
The dogs originates with a Kiwi Farms
post by a completely anonymous account
as far as I can see that has two posts.
Neither of which mention me. I don't
know how I'm supposed to have any
control over that. I don't know how I'm
supposed to take any responsibility for
that. But there's [__] This is true.
This is true. Again, I don't really want
to if I I'm probably going to show it in
my video to be fair. I just don't want
to blast the guy on stream.
Um cuz I think you should be allowed to
use Kiwi Farms. I think if you want to
have an anonymous Kiwi Farms account and
you want to post [__] you should be
allowed to do that. I don't give a [__]
Uh, but yeah, I'm not going to blast him
on stream or anything, but I'm probably
going to show the account in like a
video. Literally two posts. None of them
mention Queen. Uh, he has a ton of
reactions, I believe. I don't I full
transparency, I don't use Kiwi Farms. I
don't know how things work. I I think
they're reactions, right? Uh Cameron's
alleged alt account had the same thing.
Um
it's a ton of reactions and even the
reactions like I think two of them
mentioned Jtock but none of them mention
Quiman. So it's like okay and he's he
reacted positively to like one JTO post
and then he reacted positively to a post
making fun of JTO. So it's like it's
even a stretch to call this guy pro
Jtock. He's probably just there for the
laughs if I if I had to guess. I don't
know. But yeah, calling him a [__]
Queenman fan or anything like that,
there's just no evidence for it. It's
[__] And and and speaking of that,
speaking of that, let me let me find
this [__] People People have such like
bumblingly [__] [__] takes about
this [__]
Let me pull this up.
Dude, I love X cancel. It's so good for
stream.
So, there's like a clip here, whatever.
Uh, and then I reply, "To be clear, the
original Kiwi Farm poster has literally
no relation to Queman. Absolutely zero
mention of Quean. Willie is just lying."
Then this guy, I wouldn't say it's out
of the realm of possibility that
Queman's fans pursu uh per peruse peruse
KF.
It's like, okay, was that the
allegation? No, the allegation is that a
Queman fan doxed Willie Mack, right?
And I'm like, uh, if this is your
standard of evidence, then literally
anything is possible. This isn't
engagement. This is compliance with
Willie smear campaign. They're replying.
It's not evidence. I wouldn't I wouldn't
be surprised if some fans spent time on
KF. That's it. And it's like, dude,
they're replying to this to to, you
know, allegations that Queman's fans are
like malicious doxing freaks. And it's
like, bro, you're [__] Like, no.
Even if they were, is there any evidence
that they're doxing people? No. Okay,
then what the [__] is the point of this?
It's so [__]
Nothing I can do about this despite what
Willy Mack probably wants you to
believe. Willie Mac's basis ascribing
this to me now. A clip that takes place
weeks after Willie has already been
doxed.
He uses that to claim that I am the one
doxing him or that my fans are the ones
doxing him.
And that necessarily has to be the case
because in the clip William's talking
about, I'm reacting to a Destiny quote
tweet of Gate Fumodor. And this Gay
Fumodor person posted a video, a clip of
Bad Panard's video of uh of Willie Max
Dogs. Now, in Willy's own video,
>> hey Dark, what's up pal? He does not
blame Destiny
because by the time Destiny quote tweets
his docs, it's already viral. It's
already broadly seen.
So, I am absolutely baffled how I am
supposed to have any responsibility
when the quote tweet I am covering to
make my point about Destiny already has
like a 100,000 200,000 views. when I'm
looking at it and I have a few hundred
live and then I censor it for the the
Vault upload because obviously I don't
intend to dox Willy M. So a few hundred
people saw this through my stream when
hundreds of thousands have already seen
it through Destiny's video. Yet Willie
Mack uses that logic to absolve himself
of any culpability in Jstalks
because Destiny or Destiny's fans had
already posted it with hundreds of
thousands of views. But for some reason,
this logic that Willie Mack uses to
absolve himself doesn't apply to me.
That's not the only point where Willie
Mack is refusing to apply vindicating
logic that he knows to be true that he
knows himself to believe where he
refuses to apply it for me but is happy
to apply it for himself or for his
friends. So great example of this the
Dark Viper drama Chud was obviously
going
>> oh okay dude
off stream I've been doing a lot of
research of his Dark Viper [__] He was
so [__] dishonest in his Dark Viper
[__] I wonder what he's going to say
because there's like multiple angles you
could take with the Dark Viper stuff. Uh
he never correctly displayed Dark Viper.
Listen, I say this as someone who both
makes long- form content and someone who
streams, okay? So I I have like I have a
snake in both fights, okay? I have a
snake in both pits, as it were. All
right. Willie Mack never never in his
coverage of Dark Viper properly lays out
Dark Viper's arguments, right?
Never once. Uh, and there there's other
aspects of him being dishonest. So, I I
I really do wonder where he's going to
go with the Dark Viper stuff cuz I'm
when I'm writing this video, I'm I'm I'm
really considering including Dark Viper.
I know I know the, you know, commentary
community broadly doesn't like him,
right?
So, it might just be, even though I
think it it might be important to add,
you know, as a as a pattern to his
dishonest behavior if he just doesn't
like someone. Um, it might unironically
just be like an optics L to include
someone like Dark Dark Viper because
it's, you know, who's who's going to
really care, you know? This guy isn't
liked by anyone, so who's going to care
if he's being lied about, I guess, by
Willie. But I think um I think it is
important to address, even if not in
like a video. I do think his dishonesty
around Dark Viper is like important,
like pretty bad.
>> Went back and forth with Dark Viper
pretty hard over a copyright strike.
Kiwi Farms latched on to it. Kiwi Farms
ended up doxing Dark Viper. Dark Viper
made these Okay, I don't think it's
going to go to the angle that that
Willie was uh that Willy's been
dishonest about Dark Viper, though. I'm
sure
>> massive claims of people etching stuff
into his door, scratching stuff into his
door. And what did Willie Max say? What
did Willie Max say? He said, "You can't
ascribe that to Child Logic's community
with no evidence.
>> You're prescribing a doxing allegation
to his community based on nothing. It's
crazy.
>> You need to show some evidence to start
ascribing that to child's community. You
can't just smear him with the insane
behavior of some Kiwi farmers who happen
to have latched onto this drama." And
it's not like he's just said that once
either
in the Keles drama.
>> True.
the same points.
>> He says it's insane for careful
literally word for word describe the
actions of website
describing their actions.
>> Play the clip boy.
>> Simply because careful farms page was so
active at the time.
>> Describing the swatting or the doxing of
Kiwi Farms even though the doers
>> describing the doxing and the swatting
to Kiwi Farms is absurd.
>> Website zero is where portrays Kiwi
Farms. Kiwi Farms is a glorified gossip
forum where people troll and use slurs.
People do dox on it, but it's not what
the site is for. Saying otherwise is
like getting doxed on Twitter and then
saying all of Twitter is a doxing site.
Website zero is a malicious group of
hackers and doxers meant to harass their
target. Not just online, but in real
life as well.
Saying in her DMs with Destiny, "I was
scared website zero users aren't stupid
like Kiwi Farms users. So this whole
campaign is built off of a lie. Website
zero was too scary to go after. So she
made it about the infamous troll site
like what is 4chan next
>> when is website zero like doc spin what
is are they talking about doc spin
>> because just because there's a bunch of
activity there doesn't mean it's them
and they moderate against it they
moderate against it much like I do much
like I always I moderate against doxing
so like it's key farms level
>> it's doxing
>> obviously then he has in his careful
videos he covered keles himself he
wouldn't consider himself part of the
harass harassment against carefuls. That
would be absurd.
>> Okay, I get I mean
why why is dox been considered like
taboo? You can't talk about it but Kiwi
Farms is safe to talk about. Is there um
I guess what what's the reasoning for
that? Cuz I feel like they're they're
not you know
I don't know whatever whatever I don't
understand thing to begin with. So I I
guess one I guess could be like
incredibly taboo. one I guess could be
kosher. I I I I I don't know. Yeah. In
this video he is perfectly happy to take
a bunch of unsubstantiated harassment
claims claims from not so erodite that
my community or J community has swatted
her trying to get her deported. I hear
is being claimed
taking this absurd claim from the
schizophrenic Odashara on Twitter that J
community sent a letter to him.
Something that he's been asked for
evidence for before and has refused to
provide. He said he threw away the
letter or some [__]
>> Also, I I I get why he didn't bring this
up. I I I understand why, but this guy
only started saying that it was JTO's
community after he was banned from the
Discord, right? After he was banned from
the Discord is only when that narrative
start. Uh before that, he was, you know,
in DMs with Jtock saying like, you know,
like I don't think it's your community.
I don't think it's your community, man.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I don't think it's
your community. So, but
>> he's perfectly happy just to repeat
these with with little to no
interrogation as to the the truth of the
claims. Anyone with any [__] sense
who's left in the the pockets of
commentary community, whatever that
means at this point.
>> Yeah, sure. I really do. Yeah. has
immediately clocked that this is an
utter breach of standards, a complete
abandonment of the very logic that has
allowed their careers to flourish for 10
[__] years, 5, 10 years. the exact
delineation of responsibility drawing
clear lines where when you moderate your
community to keep a behavior out. You
can't be blamed for if some anonymous
schizophrenic who latches on to the
stuff you're saying goes and does
something in a place where you have no
control. They need that logic to stand
there. How many dramas if you accept
this logic? How many more dramas can
these people survive? How many more
dramas can William survive? How many
dramas can Nicholas Dorio survive if
that logic is accepted?
How long is it until they are covering
someone who is also being spoken about
in KF and they get doxed?
What is my level of responsibility here?
How could I have made the point I made
about Willie Mack without being accused
of dog whistling to swat his wedding?
How could I have what is a way I could
have phrased that point that Destiny's
standards leave his own supporters and
fans open to being doxed and harassed?
Harassed.
How could I have phrased that?
>> Your AI subtitles are [__] [__]
buddy. All right, I'm sorry. I hate to
bring it. I hate to I hate to say your
AI subtitles are [__] up.
>> To where Willie Mack could not have
accused me of dog whistling in the way
he did. There is not a single way
I could have phrased that where he
wouldn't be able to make that same
allegation. Especially when in the clip,
and you might not realize this when you
watch the video through a first time cuz
he chops up the clips and leaves parts,
you know, it gives a fivem minutee gap
between stuff. I explicitly state
that I'm not okay with doxing,
that I don't believe it's no bad
tactics, only bad targets. That's in
fact been a key point that I have been
hammering for five months at this point
maybe for a long time. This has been a
key point that anyone who has been even
in like osmosis range of my community
knows I have been hammering about
Destiny, about Ethan, about all these
commentary guys. There's not a wink and
a nudge. There's not a oh no but
actually we do. No, I don't.
unequivocally.
Obviously, like anyone that has watched
any of my content would know,
>> there's like not much I can Yeah, I
broadly agree. There's not much I can
say to this.
So, what am I to do?
Oh, yeah. So, two other things. So
Willie claims that it was my audience
that docked him initially,
but I had no knowledge,
nor did anyone in my community from what
I know,
uh, have knowledge of Willy's wife being
Israeli or Jewish. Now, that was
actually public. That's not even Doc's
information to say Willy's wife or
girlfriend or whatever Israeli is
Israeli or Jewish. He actually does have
old tweets
talking about how his wife's Israeli.
There's old clips of him talking about
his how his girlfriend's Israeli.
>> That is true. That is true. I don't know
about the tweets, but there are there
are 10,000% clips.
Um,
I'll bring this Yeah, I'll play this
clip again. I'm I'm probably not going
to use this at this point because I I
feel like this video as I was writing
it, I began writing this video before
Willie had published his video. Uh, and
I was just under the impression that
Willie is kind of just like a useful
idiot. He's like a [__] and that's kind
of it, right?
I didn't necessarily think he was
malicious.
Uh, so it was mostly going to be like a
light-hearted like video with like a ton
of jokes, stuff like that. Um, but as of
now, I I think he's like entirely
malicious. I think this puts a lot of
his other um a lot of his other drugs uh
into perspective.
I don't think you can I don't think it's
it's it's unfair to make the argument
that he is he hasn't always been a
malicious liar especially when you look
at cases like Dark Viper where he just
doesn't like the person. Um you know he
doesn't like Queenman. He doesn't like
JTock. Uh this opens up the door for him
to just be a malicious freak, a uh
vengeful malicious liar because you know
Quean and Jtock made him look like a
[__] idiot in a debate or some [__]
right? Uh same thing with Dark Viper. He
just didn't like Dark Viper. So when we
look at the Dark Viper [__] and he's
being dishonest to Dark Viper even
though the commentary community doesn't
like him, right?
Um to like obviously like I don't think
it's unfair to say that he's he's
dishonest to people he doesn't like
especially Dark Viper, especially Queen,
especially Jtock. Not that these people
have any relation to each other. Dark
Viper is his own can of worms or
whatever. But yeah, here's like the
clip
>> saying he has an Israeli ignorance
fallacy. You may think this was a
comment under a recent Willy Mac video,
but it was actually posted seven years
ago under a Tommy C interview.
>> Stop being such a [__] fat ass and
stop dating an Israeli.
>> Dude, don't bring that into it. She
didn't do anything
>> since then. Your video should still be
comedic. Um, not in the same way that I
was going to make it.
I still want to have jokes in it. Uh,
not in the same way though.
You can't argue serious points for [__]
I can. You're [__] You're [__]
and gay.
Literally, the only reason you think
this is because like Aiden shot on my
[__] Cameron video. The video was
fine. The points in it were fine.
If the only Okay. If the only value
you're going to derive from a video are
comedic points, uh, then yeah, don't
watch my [__] videos. Obviously,
there's going to be a serious undertone.
I have serious points against Willy
Mack. That's like [__] Make the
video funny because you can't be
serious. Then what's the point in a
[__] funny video? This guy's done
like seriously wretched [__] He is
literally doing a smear campaign. I
don't think jokes are going to be the
thing to [__] bring this guy down,
right? To be fair, I don't think my
video is ever going to bring him down.
I'm a [__] glove [__]
Uh, but no, I I don't think it's going
to be a [__] comedy focused video
with like a ton of jokes. That's not the
type of video I want to make anymore.
Uh, go watch someone else's videos.
Other people have made videos on on
Willy Mag.
Uh, where is it? I can post it in chat
and like bring it up.
Like this guy, this guy did a Willie
Mack video. If you want a video with
like jokes and humor and stuff, uh, or a
video that just isn't mine, you can go
watch other people's content.
Like, I'm not I'm not going to stop
making the type of videos that I want to
make.
This guy has like epic uh epic
>> epic Halo gameplay in the intro. This is
epic.
>> Winning
No, I'm an actual separate human being
with a brain. Okay, dude.
>> Is this is this is this funny? This is
me trying to be funny in like a recorded
scripted
video, but it was actually posted seven
years ago under a Tommy C interview.
>> Stop being such a [__] fat ass and
stop dating an Israeli.
>> Dude, don't bring that into it. She
didn't do anything.
>> Since then, Willie has made over 10
videos targeting pro Palestinian Twitch
streamer Hassanabi. Naturally, this has
sparked speculation. Is Willie Mack
compromised? This is romantic connection
to the Middle East influences
journalistic integrity.
>> Yeah, probably.
>> This is me trying to be funny in a
written scripted environment. I am not
funny. I cannot be prepared funny. I'm
that is I cannot do that. I That is not
my strong suit. My strong suit is uh is
compiling information. My strong suit is
editing. My strong suit is uh compiling
information. Uh making decent arguments
for it, I feel. And that's that.
Uh, I mean, I I I've gotten like mixed
responses on this. Some people think
it's funny, some people don't. I don't
know. I just don't think it's my strong
suit. I think my strong suit,
personally, Lady Nerd Aud, thank you for
being a member for a month. I appreciate
it. I think my strong suit is just
information compiling.
I think that is my strong suit. I don't
think it's it's being funny in a
prepared video. I don't think I have
that gene. I don't think I have that
gene. I don't. I'm sorry. I don't have
the humor gene. I don't have the the the
I don't have the comedy gene. Okay. I
did not grow up in Brooklyn, New York.
>> Or the hood. Or the hood.
>> Oh boy. Another stream. So when the made
smile,
>> I don't think I ever promised a made
moral. Uh, if someone draws me art, I'll
do it. I'm not doing that. I'm not
paying for art.
I think in a stream environment, you're
definitely funny.
Maybe. Listen, I've gotten good reviews,
okay? I've gotten good reviews, but I
don't know. I I just don't think I'm
prepared funny. Maybe I am, maybe I'm
not. I don't know. I haven't obviously
leaned into that or anything like that.
I think my strong suit is just
information compiling. Um,
I want the video to have some jokes
because I know people liked like the one
joke that was in the Cameron video.
People seem to like.
Um, so I do want to include some jokes.
Uh, but it's not it's not like I'm
definitely the one joke. Yeah, true.
Literally the one joke I think people
liked.
Um,
what was I even saying?
Yeah. No, it's just not going to be the
same video it was. I'm like rewriting
it. I'm restructuring it. Uh, it it I
think my opinion on Willie Mack has like
changed completely. It went from like
he's he's like an idiot. He doesn't
understand what he's doing wrong to he
is like completely malicious.
I don't think me like spamming [__]
always sunny clips is going to properly
comp convey that he's like a malicious
freak who is literally doing a smear
campaign on on people he doesn't like
right
[Music]
>> smile that is all smile
>> thank you ly nerd artist for the second
five I appreciate it I'll keep you I'll
keep you posted girly pop all Right.
Uh, no. I mean, there's definitely going
to be jokes in it. Um, I've been
compiling like Willie Matt clips.
There's the There's the [__]
What is it? It's like the the Hutch
interview.
Now, our wedding is being messed with,
and they were wasting the time of our
venue, the hotel, and two police
stations. It's costing me thousands of
extra dollars in insurance and
potentially closing down the entire
building and my bride is coming up.
>> But if you if you feel comfortable with
whatever details you feel comfortable
sharing.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Um I imagine that was
>> really stressful. So like you've spent
probably better.
>> Thank you for the third five. I
appreciate it.
>> All right. There's like this clip.
>> It is.
>> Yeah. I mean, I I was just about to say
I think what I think the way that we can
sort of unpack why this is the case now,
why they're just everyone is just so
okay with this kind of lying is because
I think people have watched Donald Trump
uh lie to a degree that we've literally
never like every you're talking to
Willie Mack and you're like everybody's
okay, everybody's just comfortable with
lying. Everybody's just fine with lying.
Well, there's like one specific clip I'm
trying to find.
Hold
on.
better.
[Music]
Don't tell me he cut it out of the
interview.
Surely he did not cut it out of the
the for like greater cause.
>> Well, I think it's like a mixed bag. So,
there's going to
>> If you just corrected people and were
like, "This is the truth." That person
would get obliterated every time. The
person who's lying would get obliterated
almost every time.
Uh
like right here. I think
>> the minute I turned and I criticized
that guy, like I I shouldn't be shocked
at all when I turn around when I get
doxed. Right.
>> Well, it's
>> it it escalates to these like very
realworld consequences. So for for these
people when Ethan had CPS called on him,
it was happened. Every single Instagram
post or something escalated to that's
the joke.
>> Entirely unacceptable. Like I don't know
what the the answer is for platforming
or like exciting a community who's doing
the doxing or doing the the CPS calls,
whatever we're going to call it. Um but
it just blows my mind like so many
people are okay with it. Like I swear to
God, dude, 5 years ago covering drama.
>> So many people are okay with doxing. And
he's like post like reply to Jay's dogs
docs twice.
>> If you just corrected people and were
like, "This is the truth."
>> That person would get obliterated every
time. The person who's
>> Yeah. True, true, true. If you just
corrected people, they'd get
obliterated. True.
>> Lying would get obliterated.
>> The person who's lying would get
obliterated. True.
>> Almost every time.
>> Okay. There's like a very specific clip
in here where he's like, "Um, lying is
bad. You shouldn't lie. like if you lie,
you should be [__] whatever. I can't
find I don't know if it was cut out of
the interview or whatever. It could be.
I don't know.
But back to the topic of the video. I
just don't I don't know. I'm not
confident. Maybe I'm like a little
insecure little little meek worm. I'm
like concrete. All right. And there's
like fourth graders walking home and I'm
getting stepped on in the wet concrete
by little fourth grade rain boots or
something. All right. Uh I don't know. I
just don't think I'm that funny. uh in a
prepared context.
I'm like autistic when I read stuff out
loud. I can't do it. There are going to
be jokes, just not as much. It's It's
going to be a more serious tone video.
Uh just because I think this has turned
from something that is, you know, like
Willie just being a [__] [__] I
think it's turned from Willie just being
like a a complete and utter [__] who's
like just clueless and [__]
Um it's it's changed from that into
someone who is like blatantly just
malicious, who is like openly lying,
confidently lying, uh who has a history
of being dishonest. So their recent
found malicious behavior towards people
they don't like has put their past
coverage into a different lens. Uh where
this person could have just been, you
know, insanely malicious the whole time.
The only issue is in the past they were
just doing this to people like Dark
Viper who nobody liked. So nobody gave a
[__] to to look into it, right?
Have you tried streaming while watching
the video? Streaming while watching
what?
Have you tried watching your video while
live? While editing it while li What
does that even mean? Do you want me to
react to my own video?
Sure.
You want me to react?
Yeah. W. This is W content.
>> 13,180.
That's how many messages were sent
between Glass and Only Fans models
Woloft over the course of their 204
Discord relationship. Messages that took
on a different weight after she decided
to break things off. Add to that the
dozens of YouTube community posts,
non-stop Twitter crashs, and multiple
alleged misconducts with minors. It goes
on to paint a pretty bleak picture.
Glass first began uploading GMO trolling
content on his current channel in late
2023, which he continued to do up until
around May of 2024. He then pivoted
almost entirely to VR chat trolling
content. This was around the same time
that other creators such as Proximity
Chat were already becoming successful in
this genre. All things considered,
>> what am I supposed to do here? What you
want me to look at my own videos? I like
the videos that I make. I think they're
good. I enjoy uh I enjoy like serious uh
now be funny. What am I supposed to be
funny at? What am I supposed to be funny
at? Chat being a Whoa, look. It's like
um
Socrates
Socrates mountain. And he's like pushing
the the boulder up the mountain and then
it falls back down. I don't know, dude.
What the [__] you want me to say here?
You want me to be You want me to make
jokes at my own video? You want me to
make jokes at my own video? What the
[__] is this like here? I'm so confused.
Niche game in comparison to G. You're
washed. I don't know what you want. I
don't know what you want from me. He was
doing fairly well. This would all come
to a head on the 30th of June where a
user called the 30th of June. That's
like
that's like um
10 days after 11 days after Junth the
black holiday.
That's like Junth the black George
Floyd.
George Floyd.
George Floyd knee on the neck. Knee on
the neck.
Is that what you want? You want me to
put that in the video? Then the George
Floyd joke in the in the in the Glass
video? I don't I'm so confused.
What? Zilla joined Glass's Discord
server. It quickly became apparent that
Zilla was not a fan of Glass, following
him into a voice call and accusing Glass
of copying Proximity Chat's content.
Now, it's a little silly to accuse
someone of copying content when video
game troll Yeah, I don't know. Jokes
not my strong suit. Not my strong suit.
I'm not a big jokey guy.
not a big jokey guy.
Is there a reason you ask for feedback
from people then spur out arguing with
the person who gave you the feedback? Uh
yeah, I mean I would assume feedback is
like a conversation about the thing. So
I'm not going to like lay down belly up
and just be like yes, you're right.
Obviously I want to like defend why I'm
doing something and see if I can come to
an understanding and maybe I'm right
ultimately or maybe I'm wrong.
I've definitely had my mind changed and
done things differently in videos I've
produced.
It's just like if the feedback is like
if the feedback is like if you have
Tommy C in the video, you need to
explain who Tommy C is. I'm like no, I
nobody cares who Tommy C is. You don't
need to explain that. Like obviously I'm
not going to take certain feedback just
because it's like that's not important
at all. Video is not about Tommy C.
I can't think of other examples off the
top of my head, but
no, I view I view feedback as like
conversation, not just like lay down and
and and take it because I want to I want
to understand where the other person's
coming from. If someone has an idea or
like um I guess advice, if someone has
an idea or advice, I'd want to talk to
them and understand why they're coming
from that position or why they think
that way or why why they think that
would improve the video
or improve the explanation or do
whatever. Right?
Here's an idea. The materials you look
over to produce a script, Twitter,
YouTube videos, etc. Look over them live
instead of writing a script. Walk your
stream through the material you used in
your video.
Dude, I'm like autistic. I still don't
understand. Then after write your
script, just include a joke here or
there from your stream. Oh, okay. I see.
Maybe
I see what you're saying. I thought you
were just saying like before before I
release the video, watch it live like on
stream. And I'm like, dude, what the
[__] Why? What would that do? No, but I
Yeah, I see what you're meaning. I see
what you're saying
about like gamma and stuff. When I went
to Gamma with stuff, when I went to
Gamma and I was like, "Hey, what do you
think about this edition? What do you
think about this thing?" Um, if he gave
me something, I would I I would like I
would challenge him on it because I
don't I don't want to just like
change the video without understanding
why I should change the video. I'm going
to challenge, you know, for example,
Gamma on the thing. Uh, because I want I
want to understand both why they think
that is the case that they're saying,
why it should be included instead of
what I included. uh you know, whatever.
Uh like I I would want to I would want
like a conversation about it. Not like a
debate. I'm not [__] debating anyone
or anything.
But yeah, I'm I'm I'm going to challenge
if someone gives me like criticism or
advice unless I just like wholeheartedly
agree. There there have literally been
times I I I won't name names or
anything, but like someone's like
when someone's like um
trying to think of an example. There was
something in the Cameron video. I sent
it around early and then someone's like,
"Hey, this could be better worded." And
I was like, "Yeah, that's true. I could
just change that and it would sound
better."
So, unless it's just something I
instantly agree with, yeah, I'll
challenge the person who said that. I
don't want to I want to understand. I
don't want to just like I guess uh what
would be the term? Like take their word
for it.
You're running from Aiden. Is Aiden
live?
He's not even live. Okay.
I don't know what I'm I I don't think I
am.
Gamma would make it a debate. No, I
don't think so. I mean, I I would
challenge Gamma. I don't think Gamma
ever I don't think Gamma has ever
started a conversation with me and then
turned it into a bait. It's usually me
who does that.
Stop running from Fallen Chunga is true.
Yeah, but TLDDR
the video and and what it serves to do
is has like changed in my mind. I don't
want it to be like just a ton of jokes
and like Willy's a [__] [__] This
guy's like [__] Like I think he's
like entirely malicious. I want the
video to serve as like a a coherent uh
piece about, you know, his malice and
his lies and the uh the unironic genuine
smear campaign that he's trying to do.
Uh and then potentially I I do want to
cover his Destiny videos, although the
scope of this video has changed, so I
don't know if I can justify putting the
Destiny video criticisms in there. Um
but I do want to see if I can fit in
like the Dark Viper stuff cuz he was
incredibly dishonest to Dark Viper. Um,
and then there's a couple other
situations that he was dishonest in. Um,
I still have to look into some of his
older content though to figure out what
exactly would be included. The video has
basically turned from Willy's like a
[__] like here is a critique of like
him and then his content to Willie is
like a malicious liar trying to smear
people who dislike him. Here are
multiple examples of him doing that.
That is basically what the video has
changed from. like funny. He's a [__]
Like he's kind of stupid. I don't think
he's malicious, though, too. He's
definitely malicious. Here's examples of
him, you know, being malicious.
There will be jokes in it. I have ideas
for a few bits. Um, but it's it's
definitely going to be more serious. I
guess
>> he has said that on his streams. That's
not even that wouldn't even be Doc's
information spread that. But I had no
idea until the bad empanada dox was
viral. So the idea that I had any idea
Willie Mac's wife was was Israeli Jewish
is absurd. The idea that my community
were doing it I I literally hadn't even
seen the post on KF cuz I don't [__]
read that thread every day. I just check
in when there's like some big leak I
have to grab info for.
You know it's like if there is some big
story developing. Yeah. People go to KF
like commentary YouTubers do like all
commentary like Turkey Tom, like Willie
Mac, like Nick Dioro, like any of these
people would when
they go,
>> dude. [__] Nick is such a [__]
coward.
He He has literally turned from like I
used to love his videos as well. It
sucks so bad seeing what he's turned
into because he he is literally like
Willie Mack in terms of like I'm a
normal guy. I'm a [__] normal guy.
But then he's like streaming for hours a
day,
like making thousands, tens of
thousands, potentially hundreds of
thousands on YouTube streaming. And then
he'll like lie about having a girlfriend
on Twitter. He'll like go get coffee
with like a platonic female friend, take
a picture of their hands together, and
pretend they're dating on Twitter,
and then make like a fool of himself on
the kill stream for it. It's like, bro,
this guy is [__] ridiculous. I I I
literally every YouTuber that made me
want to become a YouTuber and do like
video essay content has turned out to be
like
some ridiculous principleless like
freak. And to be I I I know I've been
going hard on like the principles lately
and whatever. To be clear, I have lied.
I will probably lie in the future. Uh
I'm not I'm not going to front. I I will
lie in the future probably.
Um I will go against my principles
probably. Uh, the best I can do is just
like correct the behavior when it
happens, right? And that's I think what
everybody can do. I think everybody's
going to lie and go against what they
believe in. Um, you know, pretty easily,
right?
I think he's he's he's going to I think
most people are going to lie. They're
going to go against what they believe in
uh for, you know, emotional reasons or
or whatever. And I think that's fine.
The best thing you can do is just um
say like,
"Yeah, I [__] up. Uh that's my bad."
You know, this is something I believe
in. I shouldn't have done that.
Whatever. And like move on, right?
That's like the best you can do. That's
the best you can ask for. So, to be
clear, like, yeah, I like to think I
have principles. I like to think I have
things that I believe in, uh you know,
that I want to fight for and whatever.
Uh but yeah, I I nobody's perfect. I
think most people are going to lie. Most
people are going to make mistakes.
Whatever. just learned from it I think
is the the whole thing and I don't see
Nick for example doing that. I don't see
Nick for example um you know explaining
why his mind has changed on so many
things and he has basically changed
entirely as a content creator and his
mindset as a content creator has changed
like completely
uh like you know he'll he has no issue
with going after his friends once the
tides have turned you know with Mudahar
once the tides have turned he'll [__]
do Muda content with Bobs once the tides
have turned he'll do blacks content and
then with Willy Mack if the tides turn
he'll probably do Willie Matt content.
It is um it's just like really pathetic
to see.
And I know to be clear, I know there's
more nuance in like the Muda and than
the Bobby [__] I know stuff happened
that led him. It wasn't literally just
like people started making fun of his
friends. Now he's going to make fun of
his friends, right?
visit because that is where they
compile. That's the word I'm looking
for. Compile archives of
>> Dude, I feel like I've just like I've
just made everyone so depressed by like
talking seriously. We got to get
whimsical. Okay. Where is like uh is
there like a funny funny
cat videos?
Let's watch
funny cat talking moment. Let's get our
whimsy back, folks.
>> Hold on. Best cat videos of the decade.
>> These are the best cat videos from the
past 10 years.
>> Okay.
All right. Whoa.
That's a crippled cat. That is That is a
cat with no back legs.
>> Do you record yourself reading a script?
Yeah. How else do you re How else do you
get the audio for the vid? Yes, I do
record myself. Yeah, I do do that, dude.
Sorry. Sorry, liberal. Okay,
dude. She's eating the cat. This is
[__]
>> You can't even What are you hitting him
with? You have no other arm.
>> What did you just say?
Whoa, look at that one. He went through
the the sheet metal.
[Applause]
>> This cat is not being harmed in any way
and truly enjoys doing this trick.
>> It's a little flip.
>> Two double mama hugs.
[Music]
Whoa. That cat was being crushed.
>> That cat was being killed.
[Music]
>> These people use their cat to catch a
bug.
>> Wow.
>> Okay, I think we've gotten our whimsy
back. I think we've gotten our whimsy
back. Okay, we're back in the mood.
Let's keep it going. Five more minutes.
I'm 10.
So if someone in a big situation is
taking stuff down, leaking stuff, it's
going to be posted there.
It's going to be posted there. And
they've defended that.
>> Don't do it anymore.
>> The use of it,
>> what is the alternative to reading a
script?
What is the alternative?
>> Destiny has defended the use of it.
>> That was the whole careful arc. That was
the whole thing
was you can't just use ancillary
connections to KF to ascribe all the
responsibility for KF's actions to Green
is in my head. I'm confused on what he
wants KF's
>> I live to serve but I'm I'm confused
to blame KF for all swatting. You can't
just draw these connections of
responsibility to try and rope everyone
in and shut down criticism which is what
they're doing. Make no mistake that is
what Willy's doing. He has been fighting
with us for months, for months, and only
now attempts to even remotely engage
with anything anyone said in one of his
videos because why? Because
he found an opportunity to shut shut
down criticism. Obviously,
on top of that, one of Destiny's dogs
attempts on me is in both of his videos.
A name is in both of his videos. And in
his second video, he plays a portion of
the released cherry audio, the
non-consensual cherry audio, nonsexual
portion, and shows all the KF posts of
where to find it.
>> True. to the idea that I am getting
blamed for leaving a video playing on
autoplay that Destiny has already quote
tweeted to 200,000 people. The idea that
I am getting blamed for that live when I
censored it in the upload got throwaway
to censor it on Twitter even though I
usually don't control the people that
[__] clip my [__] at all. I know I
don't like making recommendations to
them or anything like that. Willie had
to be basically pressured into fixing
the cherry stuff. It's like totally
absurd.
Willie does not care. Which I've I've
I've heard like multiple explanations
about the Cherry [__] I wish we could
get like a screenshot or something
proving this. Jay Stocker said on stream
uh that Cherry asked him in private to
remove it and then he didn't so she had
to go through YouTube legal to get it
removed. Um I just wish there was like
any any evidence of that because if
that's true, that's pretty damning,
right?
Just make an outline with things you
want to touch on. That is lit. No,
absolutely not. That is what Becket
does. And I don't like Beckett's videos.
Becket does not script. He just like
talks out loud and it it it makes for
insufferable content. I would rather
have uh like a structure. I do do like
an outline. I do do like a thesis for a
video and then I write around that. Um
but no, absolutely not. I'm going to
keep scripting.
I would rather have cohesive arguments,
a a script that flows well, etc.
than, you know,
have to [__] listen to myself ramble
and then cut even more out figuring out
what sounds good, what is fine,
whatever.
Take off the [__] and ball chain. Free
yourself. I can't even tell if you're
memeing. I can't even tell if you're
memeing. I'm so No, I No, I'm going to
keep scripting. I enjoy the scripting
process. I'm going to keep doing that
>> about this doxing incident. Okay, this
is pretense. Purely pretense because
it's a safe way to swing at me, to swing
at J, to swing at Ory because we put
pressure back because there has been
he's hit a kind of wall. He's feeling
some pressure and he wants to take a
swing. And I'm pretty confident, even
more so than I would be from just the
previously public information, that this
is the case because just now, just
within the last hour or two, Ogie
appeared on Chud's stream when Willie
started talking about sort of how he was
feeling. Or he tried to
>> being fast and loose could it can work
for some people.
I mean, there are some Becket videos
that I like. I just don't think it works
for me.
You're what what you're basically you're
telling like a woodworker to go like
[__] weld. It's like, yeah, I'm sure
they could weld, but it's like probably
not going to be good at it. I I I
definitely want to stick to what I know,
especially for a video like this.
Why is Jimberly DMing? What is this?
Is this just a video of you?
This is just you're a three-year-old
video of you swatting down a fly. Why
are you sending me this?
[Laughter]
is dude. This is just
how you're literally like 30. This was
three years. Did it fart? Did he fart?
Yeah.
This is just Is this you three years
ago? Why do you You're like 30. You're
actually like You're actually [__]
You're actually [__]
Jimberly. What is this?
It's not me.
It's not me. It's not me. It's not me.
It's a family member. I swear I I'm
older than that. I'm older than that.
I'm older than that.
It's not me. I swear it's not. Stop.
Stop. Stop. Stop.
Yeah.
Dude.
Why? What is the point of this video?
What is this account?
Burn to death or what the [__] are you
tweeting?
There was actually a Reddit post about
Queen.
Do you guys know that Queman's Reddit
has a snark?
ran into Queen IRL and there's something
really off about him. I saw Quimman at a
grocery store in London yesterday. I
told him it was cool to meet him in
person, but I didn't want to be a douche
and bother him and ask for a photo or
anything. He said, "Oh, like you're
doing now?" I was taken aback and all I
can say is, "Huh?" But he kept cutting
me off and going, "Huh? Huh? Huh?" and
closing his hand shut in front of my
face. I walked away and continued with
my shopping and I heard him chuckle as I
walked off. When I came to pay for my
stuff up front, I saw him trying to walk
out the doors with like 15 Milky Ways in
his hands without paying. The girl at
the counter was very nice about it and
professional and was like, "Sir, you
need to pay for those first." At first,
he kept pretending uh to be tired and
not here, but eventually he turned
around and brought them to the counter.
When she took one of the bars and
started scanning it multiple times, he
stopped her and told her to scan them
individually to prevent any electrical
interference and then turned around and
winked at me. I don't even think that's
a word. After she scanned each bar and
put them in a bag and started to say the
price, he kept interrupting her by
yawning really loudly.
[Laughter]
Queman Snark. Dude, the Queenman Snark
Reddit is picking up is picking up
shame. There was a post after after a
one month hiatus. There has been a new
post 3 hours ago by the same guy. This
is the only guy that posts in the Queen
and Snark, by the way. the only guy who
posts in the Queen Star.
It's just one guy. It is one guy who
runs this Reddit page.
Just one guy. He's come away. He's
returned 3 hours ago. Aiden based
takeman is so [__] soft on Destiny.
It's ridiculous. I'm starting to wonder
if he's controlled opposition at this
point.
There's some other posts as well.
Queenman sees over Snark subreddit.
R/Qman Snark was created the same exact
day and time that Queman was massively
botted. Will anyone talk about this
major injustice and harassment by of
Quean by Snark? Jews are not allowed to
stream.
Queenman's still in bed at 3:15 on a
Monday. I'm in bed, but I can call in if
you want, dude.
Quimman bullies save a Fox and mocks her
for her only fans. Queman uses death of
Savox to hate on H3. Quean hasn't said a
word on stream for almost 5 minutes.
Literally hosting a watch party.
Queen bots his subscribers. Queen view
and like bots his streams.
My fellow queman, what is my fellow que
lamers? The time is upon us. Pardon?
He's come back though. I'm so glad.
Three hours ago today. I wonder what
happened. Was he arrested? Maybe. Was he
detained?
Was he detained? You guys think? I don't
know.
Curious stuff. Curious stuff.
sort of push back and ask a couple
questions. Be like, "Oh, what are they
doing? They're harassing you. What's
what's happening?"
And Willie freaked out.
Willie freaked out. Willie instantly
apparently goes to Orgie. Are you
recording me right now? You trying to
set me up? Because he fears that I or or
Chud or someone is in everyone's ear
trying to turn people against this guy.
And that that's why all of a sudden
people are talking [__] about him. why
all of a sudden people are saying,
"Wait, is this guy retarded?" Not
because of his own embarrassing actions.
Not because for a long time his videos
have been swept for despite being utter
dog [__] being essentially clip
compilations that fail to make any
argument through the entire runtime in
some of them. Not because
he has no understanding of the
principles he espouses and simply adopts
them because they're convenient from the
groups that he's in, but because I must
have, and this is a Destiny narrative,
too. I must have me a sub 10k hardtock
sub 10k 500 viewer max streamer control
the entirety of H3 snark kiwi farms
commentary YouTube the Destiny community
castoffs
Hassan [__] and his entire community I
somehow am the epicenter the divergence
point for these communities where
everything comes together the person
pulling everything together. I'm hearing
Destiny compare me to Hamas apparently
on stream today. Something that is
hysteria that is beyond parody. And for
what? Because I was just the first guy
saying, "Hey, maybe people are going a
little bit too far and excusing actions
against people that are against their
own principles."
>> True.
>> And now apparently I'm the guy who's no
bad tactics, only bad targets. After
months of fighting on that, after
hemorrhaging viewers for 3 to 6 months
over that exact position, over arguing
that exact position
for people that I don't have any
sympathy for, particularly Hassan Per,
bad empanada,
whoever it is, they've decided to sign a
Denims TV
like I give a [__] about denims.
But somehow somehow they have found a
way to just manufacture
this desperate smear when I have for
months laid out exactly what my
criticisms are. Think for all these
people
who claim Willie who says this all the
time.
If you've got an issue with my video, if
you've got an issue with something I
said, respond to it. Fire up a live
stream and react. do a response video.
Why is it
that Will the only engages? Ask
yourself, why is it that Willy only
engages with a single clip where he can
cry victim in a completely incoherent
way with the rest of the arguments in
the video about doxing and his wedding
and his bride? Why is it that that is
the only thing Willie engages with?
>> I extremist propaganda.
>> I think the answer's pretty clear.
Yeah, true. I don't have much much.
Yeah, I I don't have a lot to say. I
agree. I agree broadly. I agree broadly
with that. Yeah, I agree pretty much.
Pretty much entirely with that. And then
Auggie replies to this.
Uh 100% emoji.
Perfectly said. Willie Max smeared us.
Plain and simple. He lied about our
coverage on him and used arguments he
doesn't even believe in. Insane that
people can watch this video and see
otherwise. True.
True.
Um, yeah, true. I mean, I just agree
with that. There's not much to not much
else to say. I just agree with that. Uh,
it is literally is unironically
genuinely doing a smear campaign. Uh, he
has turned in my eyes, I said this
before on stream. I'm going to repeat
myself. Okay, I'm going to repeat
myself. I'm looping. I'm looping. I'm
deranged. I'm looping. He has turned
from like an idiot, a useful idiot, a
[__] uh who will just get mistakes,
who will, you know, mistake uh
misinformation accidentally, stuff like
that, uh to someone who in my eyes is is
nothing other than completely malicious.
When you look at past dramas with people
who he covered, who he didn't like, uh
you know, being uh the the the only one
that really comes to mind as of now is
is Dark Viper, right? Look at his Dark
Viper coverage. He never accurately
displays Dark Viper's position. Is that
out of ignorance or is that because this
guy at the time scorned Chud Logic by
taking down one of his videos, right? Is
this because he was friends with Chud
Logic at the time who was scorned by
Dark Viper. So, he had a little bit of a
hate boner against Dark Viper. Made
multiple videos against Dark Viper,
being bad faith, not representing his
argument properly or correctly at all.
In all of the videos he's made, not once
has he properly displayed Dark Viper's
argument.
M check DMs.
It's super important.
What if you DM me?
If Lio Convoy was a dog warts, what
breed would he pick? Um,
what are those dogs with like the the
barrels on their chests?
What is it? St. Bernard.
These [__] These little these little
these little critters.
Look at this. I'm I'm sure he'd go for
this like puppy, too. He's like a
pedophile dog [__] Okay.
Joke. Joke. He would He would wait until
it was ready. it. He would wait until it
was he was fully grown.
He would wait. He would wait. Okay. He
is not a pedophile dog [__] He would
wait until the dog is mature. I'm sure.
Okay. I'm sure.
I'm sure. Wink wink. I'm sure he
wouldn't [__] the puppy. Wink wink.
Nudge nudge. Hey, I'm sure. I'm sure he
wouldn't. I'm sure he wouldn't. Wink
wink.
All right. I'm sure he wouldn't.
He'd be a Chihuahua. All bark, no bite.
Yeah, true.
What? Did you watch that on stream?
That's foul. I'm just being honest. Are
you streaming right now? What? Yeah, you
are. Okay. What did you say?
>> Carry around in our pockets. And we did.
>> What' you say? Are you talk to me off?
You're not even
you're not even watching my stream
>> or a program called MIRC and MRC is
essentially discord but the ability to
call
>> do they say what I chose.
So
>> it sounds like we have really good
strong family genes. What went wrong?
Why did the short end of the genetic
sick? What happened?
>> This is a family. So first thing you
want to do first thing be with your kids
they'll take longer here now and that's
why yes they don't think why they want
but
that's crazy so that's why you have that
>> yeah between them the parent and the
child um also just just education in
general uncle just just comment like
don't use your real name online
but don't
I want to hear what they said on stream
about it and then we'll move on. I think
>> ironically to Malcolm content
>> Rosie in chat.
What chat are they in this one?
What chat are Rosie in chat? Which young
adult is cuter, Aiden or Mau?
Scroll down.
Oh, Malcolm, which young adult streamer
do you think is cuter, Aiden or Morau?
Jesus.
I mean, it's obviously Aiden. I would
not [__] Aiden, though. Dickers, on the
other hand, we can have a conversation
about that. Okay. Oh, that's a really
good question. Right now, isn't he?
That's a really good question. Pause. I
need morale thoughts on this. Hang on.
Where are we here? I need to get my DMs.
I need to message morale. Where am I?
>> Please. There is. There he is. Um,
morale. If Lio Conboy was at Dog Warts,
what breed would he pick? And then I'm
going to get in stream
>> properly or correctly at all. All of the
videos he's made, not once properly
displayed. Dark Viper argument.
>> Please answer on stream.
>> Check DMs is super important.
What did he get me?
If Lio Convoy was a dog warts, what
breed would he pick? Um, what are those
dogs with like the the barrels on their
chests?
>> The barrels on their chest. What? Like a
bulldog?
>> What is it? St. Bernard.
>> These [__] These little these little
these little puppy.
>> I'm sure he'd go for this like puppy,
too.
>> He's like a pedophile.
>> Oh, dude.
>> Joke joke. He would he would wait until
it was ready. He He would wait until it
was he was fully grown.
>> He would wait. He would wait. Okay. He's
not a pedophile dog [__] He would
wait until Listen,
>> I'm glad I'm glad I'm finally being done
justice here.
>> We did not even have a contgo
reality of what goes on. They think that
a child predator somebody down the
street. They don't think that child
predation isn't just what happens in
terms of physical touch. You can also be
listening.
>> So true, man.
Uh
>> okay. W Is there anything else to say
about this? Probably not. I mean, I I
just agree with what both of they said
pretty much is
Willy's like turned from like a [__]
bumbling [__] to like a a malicious,
dishonest uh smearing like piece of
[__] Basically, Destiny acts like he
hasn't partly built his career off of
having a dedicated clippers and Twitter
and Reddit accounts dedicated to posting
them, something many comic creators do
not is, which he'd eventually weaponize
against its detractors. Destiny has
admitted to having spies in other
communities and active doctors he's also
weaponized that are in his community to
further his campaign of intimidation
narrative control against victims and
those attempting to hold him
accountable. Destiny replies, "I
weaponize my clips and clippers by
clipping factual statements about
politics, not obsessing weirdly over
losers personal lives. I'm really uh
ready to take anyone to the mat as far
as arguments on the facts goes. If
you're weirdos and creeps who take uh
who make everything personal or sexual,
this is [__] [__] This is
[__] [__] Uh Queman,
which is the always be qui quipping or
whatever quipping. [__] I'm tired,
dude. I'm tired. I'm starting to [__]
get mushmouthed. Uh he literally just
says like clip my streams. Clip whatever
is on my stream that you think is funny.
Clip it and post it, you know? Uh he's
not saying, you know, go around and clip
[__] sexual [__] or personal stuff.
Uh that is people doing as they seem
deep fed.
This is [__] This [__] sucks.
If I wasn't as tired, I think I'd watch
the Hutch uh the Hutch interview. I
might do that off stream tomorrow. I
wasn't even planning on going streaming
today, on doing streaming or going live
or whatever.
I'm [__] losing it, dude. I'm losing
it. I got like four hours of sleep.
I'm losing my mind. I'm losing my mind.
Uh Quimman constantly encourages his
fans to create Twitter accounts to clip
stuff uh and run narrative control
online. He does not run. He does not
encourage them to run narrative control.
He literally just says clip.
There's no proof of anything uh
narrative control.
This is just [__] This sucks.
Mean something about this message seems
[__] to me. I don't want to I don't
want to I don't want to dive into that.
I appreciate it. Something about this is
evil, though.
It's for narrative control. It's to dive
uh drive traffic to his channel so he
can make more money. True. Keep in mind
Destiny has explicitly stated the
position, if you see something, say
something in regards to defending him
online. Yeah. I mean, this is [__]
It's just [__] [__] Dude, this
whole Willie [__] in general has like it
has me so [__] I might be chronically
online for this. Okay, this [__] has me
like genuinely upset.
Uh, and I could be chronically online
for this take and call me out for that.
Please tell me. You guys need to tell me
if I got to go outside more, okay? Be be
the first. Please. But it's just like
why why are people just just so willing
to lie? I guess maybe I'm naive. Maybe
I'm naive. Maybe I've you know not I
I've not had many uh you know real real
world experience. I've had you know so
maybe this is just how things are and
and I'm just naive and I'm I'm finding
out how the real world is. But it's just
it's just so it's just so depressing
how willing people are just to lie. Like
Mantis even uh like Mantis, Tom Foolery,
[__] Aerodite, Destiny, all of these
people.
It's just like bro,
I don't understand it.
Like even Willie, like before the
Destiny [__] I had some semblance of
respect for him and then he just ignored
all the criticism and it's like, "Okay,
dude." And then he's he's literally
doing [__] smear campaigns and it's
like, "Bro,
what are we doing? This is so [__]
bizarre. This just sucks so much.
I don't understand it." Um,
I definitely need to get less invested
in this [__] because this is like
genuinely like maddening to me and I'm
not even involved,
you know? I'm not even the one being
accused of hosting a [__] doxing
community. I'm not even the one being
[__] smeared. And it's like
upsetting. It's just upsetting to see
this like be normalized and happen.
I don't know.
I really really really I am going to
work [__] hard. I really want my my
Willie video to be good. Um and it's
like perceived as [__] I really want it
to be good. Cuz I am I am
extraordinarily passionate about this. I
am extraordinarily passionate about
this. I think this is disgusting that
this is happening. Uh this is not the
commentary YouTube that I, you know, got
interested in and started watching and
that inspired me to make my channel and
make videos. Um this is something like
completely different. It's like just
it's it's completely just full of of
spineless cowards and people with no
principles and liars who will not take
accountability and own their shed. Um,
Destiny's trying to play both sides
where he's like pro doxing, complicit in
doxing, but then also doxing is like
evil and bad.
It's just like, man, what?
I don't get it.
Well, you said lying is okay. Dude, this
is What are you doing, Green? I liked
you better when you were sending like
cryptic messages and like $5 donos.
Okay.
I actually didn't. That was very um That
was very uh paranoia inducing. That was
very I I I had dreams about you. Okay. I
had dreams.
As someone who at the beginning of this
all thought you were all were being too
much with Willie, I'm 100% on board uh
with y'all at this point of him being
crazy. Yeah.
It's not even just this. like he has a
history of doing this, right? I thought
it was I I didn't think it was malicious
to be clear. Check his live tab.
Destinies.
I didn't think it was malicious. I
thought, you know, maybe he read
something and just assumed it was real
or whatever. And at this point, I I I
can't give him that grace. Like, I feel
like all of the mistakes he's made, uh,
you know, against people he doesn't
like, they have to be malicious at this
point. And the only reason he got away
with it is because like with the Dark
Viper [__] uh, people don't like Dark
Viper. This community does not like Dark
Viper because he [__] with Chud,
right?
So, it's like,
how many times has he done this is what
I'm trying to get at. How many times has
he done this and just gotten away with
it because nobody's cared, nobody's
looked into him, right?
The trans athlete is going to do a lot
to like
Testing, testing.
>> Hey, hello.
>> Oh, hi. What's up, buddy?
>> Um, uh, not much. Just uh, yeah, I've
been kind of like got
>> and [__] like this, dude. I I'm going to
have a soy take. Okay, I'm going to have
a soy Oh, [__] Wait, wait. MCMD is
here. McMad, can I call you? I got a
question about about F2M.
Can I call you? What's your What's your
Discord? Why did I look up I I went to
the search where I typed in F tom?
That's not going to help me. Make mad.
Can I call you?
An actual question. Yeah. Yeah, I'm
calling you. Pick up.
Pick up the phone.
I'll play that play that cool song I
found. Where is it?
Ooh.
Hey.
>> Hey.
>> If you were to like go bald, is that
gender affirming?
[Music]
>> Uh, I'm probably not going bald,
>> dude. It's like almost 2:00 a.m. here.
>> If if you if you started like
norwooding, would you look at yourself
in the in the mirror and be like, "Fuck
yeah, this is cool."
>> Uh, maybe. Are you
>> No, not you. You You are You would know
how you feel.
>> I I'd have to wait for it to happen.
>> No, [__] You know, you know.
Stop giving softball [__] answers,
[__] Do you want to be bald? Do you
want to have male pattern baldness?
Would that be gender affirming?
Uh, definitely. Yeah, for sure.
>> Why were you so scared to just admit
that? Why were you so scared to just
admit that you that Yeah, you would like
it if you went bald.
>> Um,
I'll be honest. I'm
sorry. I thought I heard I heard
something outside. I'm like kind of
tired right now, so I'm not very good at
answering questions.
Do you look at like um
do you look at like Nicholas Cage's
hairline and you're like a little
jealous?
>> Not really.
[Music]
>> You sure?
>> Nicholas Cage was never really like
somebody I went for. Um
well,
not not anybody really. Who's the fat
guy from uh War Dogs?
>> Is War Dogs even a movie? Yeah, it is.
Who's this guy? Jonah Hill is Jonah. Are
you a big Jonah Hill guy?
>> Uh, not really.
>> Dan Bazerian is in this movie. What the
[__]
Huh?
All right, we'll look at we we'll look
into that after this. What do you do you
think like do you think like an an M to
F would be gender affirmed by like
getting cat called in like New York?
>> I think some of them would. Yeah.
>> Okay.
Are you really gender affirmed by
Norwood or are you just saying that to
appease me?
>> I'm just saying that, dude. I don't
know.
>> Go [__] yourself.
>> I'm tired of these [__] [__]
They're too scared. They're too [__]
scared to say to say the truth.
>> I'm just saying I'm I'm just saying I
want a Norwood to make you happy. I'm
just saying I want a Norwood to make you
happy.
[__] you.
[Music]
Where is Dan Bilzerian in this movie?
He really is in this movie.
[Music]
Dandelzerian is really in the movie War
Dogs.
[Music]
Wow.
Ellie is F to M. Ooh,
rough.
All right, let's watch a bit of this. As
I was saying before we got interrupted
by the uh the trans discussion, [__]
like this is just so blackmailing
because he's like, I I've been I've been
told about this interview. I don't know
if it's true. I don't know what about it
is true. Um, but if if if I'm being told
an accurate representation of this
interview or whatever, Destiny's just
like gaslighting this guy into thinking
he did nothing wrong. And it's like,
bro, no. You're like a weird drug addict
freak who like abuses women. You You
need to get help. You need to get help.
Don't run to DG and make your life
worse.
Why are you willing to call Destiny?
This is like the worst thing you can do.
If you thought somehow If you thought
somehow that taking a picture with
[__] Ethan Klein was bad, this is
that times a million, [__] What
are we doing? What are we doing?
Let's watch it, though.
>> Got a haircut and um ready to ready to
talk. Um there were a couple things I
want to say beforehand.
>> Sure.
>> Wait, you know that I'm like live
everything, right? So,
>> yeah, I know you're live. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Um
>> what is
this clip? Is this MP4? This is not
[__] MP4. Holy [__] If you guys If
you guys send me clips, make sure they
are [__] MP4.
Make sure they are MP4 so I can click
and drag them into my [__] browser so
I can watch them that way so I don't
have to [__] download them and
convert them to MP4 from [__]
Send me MP4 clips. Holy [__] How is
this that hard? How is this that hard to
comprehend?
I will download this clip and convert it
though because I the worst part is I
don't even know if this is I don't even
know if this is if this is worth
bringing up on stream. I don't even know
if this is worth bringing up on stream.
I had to [__] convert this to MP4.
Sorry. Sorry. Let's pull it up.
chat. If you see anyone from DGG like
trying to dox or harass any of the
idiots on Twitter, message me about it
on Discord or in chat. If you don't have
Discord, snitch on your friends. Do not
allow them to lower the bar of this
community by being [__] Do not dox
do not harass people. Also, as a general
rhetorical rule, don't argue or debate
with people. If you see somebody post
something negative, post something
positive. If somebody's saying like, oh,
like, why is this guy why does he hate
black people? Like, hey, check out
Mark's position on marijuana. One of the
big reasons why he's uh supportive of it
is because it represents a huge equity
challenge for people of color in the OMA
community. Or hey, check out Mark's like
LGBTQIA plus positions or whatever that
he has listed on his website, right?
Focus on the positives. It's the most
important thing you can do, right?
Performative performative statement. Is
it performative? You can look at the
bottom right. This is 2021. This is
2021. I think this is before he went
evil. This is this is pre-plug. This is
pre-plug, folks. I mean, I agree with
this completely. I agree with this
completely. And I will reiterate this. I
will reiterate this. If there are
doxers, I say my community. My Discord
has maybe a hundred people and there's
like 40 people watching the stream.
If if there are doxers, yeah, contact a
mod. Contact the content creator. Okay.
Contact anyone. Yeah. I do not want
doxers around here. I do not want
anybody breaking uh Discord to I don't
want anyone doxing. I don't want anyone
um you know anyone like that obviously.
Yeah, contact a mod in the whatever
server, whatever community you reside
in. Um contact the content creator if
the mod ignores you. Uh even even
honestly honestly I'm I'm fine with you
know making a fuss on Twitter.
I'm fine with making a fuss on Twitter.
Unironically, I am I am pretty okay with
Destiny uh outing Spencer Howard how he
did because yeah, it was not okay for
Spencer to post a doc. That is bad. He
should have been banned. I like Spencer.
I'll gladly accept his money. I don't
give a [__] on that front. But yeah, if
Spencer was posting a uncensored docs,
yeah, ban him.
Food shops and Destiny talking. You sure
you is that real?
Did they make it?
>> Won't happen.
>> Nice. So that um that spin boy ban I
think was because he was making fun of
just for platforming Cherry. You saw the
um a long time ago when Cherry leaked.
>> His ban was way before that
>> that Justicle told her that he'd be her
Dr. K, right?
>> Yeah, I I've heard about that. I mean, I
haven't [__] I I should have double
checked whether or not that screenshot
actually exists, but at this at this
point, like literally That wasn't just a
screenshot. That was literally um
that was literally um
that was Cherry tweeting. It wasn't just
like a random chat. That was Cherry like
tweeted that.
>> Wait, I remember. I remember. I remember
when when Cherry first um came out with
all that leaks and [__] like that. Yeah,
I I actually remember now. I actually
Okay. Yeah. Okay. I remember. I
remember.
>> Listen, I just sent I sent Short Fat
Otaku a DM and I DM'd him saying,
"Hello, Short Fat Otaku. I'll see if I
can get my own Destiny on stream. I'll
see if I can get short fat otaku on
stream,
dude. And like look at the chat. Look
who's in the chat. It's Mantis.
My god. Like, bro.
Like again, it's just it's just so
depressing. Um
big big things happening on this front,
folks.
Hold on. Big things happening on the
short fat otaku front.
[Laughter]
Big things happening on this front,
man. Imagine if you succeeded in fixing
Mantis. I don't think I could have. I
don't think I could have.
[Laughter]
Big things happening. Huge things
happening on this front. Okay.
actually unhinged. I'm sorry. That's
actually just [__]
dude. And and
>> okay, maybe not big things. They said
WTF, lol.
No, I don't want to have sex with you.
Not what I was getting at
like want to want to want to call in.
Smile.
Like that angle of thing. [__] I might
have fumbled, folks. Oh no. This is
Jesus. I might have sent I sent all of
that in all caps, by the way. This is
not looking good.
This is not looking good. Make Dev watch
the stream he did arguing with his wife.
I wouldn't do that.
Like I Jesus [__] dude. I might have I
might have I might have fumbled the bag
with short fat otaku. Holy [__] This is
not looking good. This is not looking
good, folks. You know what's even
crazier? What's even crazier is that um
and and this could be just some cruel
twist of irony or something because like
Dr. K like went under fire for all the
[__] thing about like um um God who
who is that one friend of
>> That's evil
>> who was a streamer was
>> Reckful.
>> Yeah, Reckful, right? So, so it's like
it's kind of crazy now in retrospect
like how this parallels because like
Cherry is also Cherry's also like
[__] depression and but why the [__]
would he say that? Why the [__] would he
say? Because now he's saying like,
"Yeah, you know what? I'm going to do
you like wreckful." Like that's that's
kind of what I'm thinking.
>> Well, that was I mean remember hold on
screenshot. Remember this is like
literally what Cherry was saying, right?
Imagine
her saying this back in February and
he's still bringing her on stream every
single day. Like, imagine how insane
that is.
>> This is
>> I mean, who cares if he brings her on
stream?
Who gives a [__]
Why does food [__] mog you in views? Cuz
uh I'm assuming they got a raid by When
did Destiny end?
12-hour kit. It was not a Destiny raid,
actually.
streamed live 12 hours ago. It No, it
was not. Why am I thinking it was um
I'm assuming they got raided. And
Destiny's on. They're literally talking
to Destiny. They're literally talking to
Destiny. So, that's probably why they
have so many views.
>> And generally, they have more viewers
than me. They have more viewers than me.
>> Uh I mean, there's probably a reason
why. I I Yeah, I don't know.
Cherry, I think Destiny J. Stock and uh
and and every sorry not I and every
person in my life is trying to make me
kill myself. I sorry making I think I'm
going to be dead soon. I mean dude,
honestly like Yeah. I mean, dude, do you
even think that Okay, tell me your
honest opinion. Do you even think that
Jay Silk even likes Cherry?
You think there's
>> I don't know
>> cuz I don't
>> I don't Bro,
do you think they even like each other?
Yeah, man.
That's the Okay, whatever. I mean, sure.
Sure.
It's a scop. It's a scop.
See, that's the scary question because I
want to be able to believe that. Oh,
wow. Truly
>> Cherry should not be on the internet.
JTO is a [__] He created his weak
spot. Uh, I don't give a [__] I don't
care. Cherry is like in her mid to late
20s. Uh, I think she is capable of being
online if she wants to be online. She's
not [__] 14. If she wants to be
online, she can be online. If she wants
to date a streamer, she can date a
streamer. Uh if she wants to do
something uh she can do it. I'm uh I'm
not going to infantilize her. That's
kind of in my opinion [__] to do.
That's just me.
>> Love even exists among trolls or
something, right? But like the thing is
is like I feel like I feel like Jto
would be kind of
>> he uh short fat otaku has has ceased
responding to my DMs. I'm thinking that
front is uh kind of cooked, kind of
over. Okay. diabolical enough to take
advantage.
>> What [__] said that it's like right up
here. This this clip clip guy, I don't
know how to say her name. I'm sorry.
>> Cherry like that, which is insane.
>> The issue is that I think it's really
insane to be platforming Cherry when you
know that she has such a huge issue
being online with all of this stuff
>> and you literally had her committed.
Remember that.
>> I mean, you platformed Anna.
You platform I mean, dude, I Who cares?
These people are adults. You can do
whatever.
You had her committed. Yeah, she was
threatening to kill herself. I think
it's fine to have her committed. Does
that mean she's going to try to kill
herself every single time she's on
stream? No. Who cares? Who cares? I
don't care that she's on stream. I'm not
going to infantilize her. She's not a
[__] [__]
Yeah, if someone threatens to kill
themselves, I don't care if you [__]
do a 5150 on them. Who cares? That's
like a non-issue. He's like the the
issue with the Cherry thing and I do
think Jtock is [__] for doing this
because it gives just like the the
easiest [__] dunk on him ever. It's
like you're you're dating Cherry like
whatever. Sure. It's like an easy dunk.
He can't complain at this point. He's
done it to himself. But it is very
frustrating. These people basically had
nothing on Jtock.
Basically, these people had literally
nothing on JTOK.
Uh, and then now that, you know,
now that the whole cherry thing
happened, it's like that's the only
angle they can go from and they know it
gets to him. They know the cherry [__]
gets to him. So, it's like it's the only
thing they can use and it works. So,
it's like it's it's very frustrating to
see. Uh, you know, cuz I like Jtock. I
like JTO. Uh, but he did do a a [__]
[__] Uh,
you know,
and and Cherry's also at at fault.
Nobody knew about this until Cherry
outed it, right?
So Cherry's at fault, Juck's at fault,
both of these people kind of [__] up
in my opinion. Yeah. If she wants to be
online, if she wants to do whatever, you
know, she can do whatever.
>> That means that he called the police and
said that she was suicidal and the
police locked her up for 3 days,
>> right? And then immediately after he's
bringing her back on stream to farm her
for her content to attack me. And
>> true mean true. I agree. I'm glad that
even people that dislike uh JTO realize
that this is just a you know [__]
[__] tactic by Destiny.
Do you have anything else? Has Jtock
doxed anyone? No. Okay. Well, I mean,
you know, it's just a [__] tactic.
Whatever.
>> I feel like that's pretty [__] crazy.
Do you do you remember do you remember
when um it wait was it you can confirm
to me whether or not this is true. Okay.
But is it is it true that J Stelk and
Cherry then tried to spin that as like
>> um that that it was actually her husband
that called her and then called her to
the psych ward. Do you know they tried
to make a narrative like that at some
point?
>> Okay. Just asking. Well, I've I've heard
about
>> Jess tries to be very much like he tries
to be above it all by claiming that like
he doesn't want to talk about his
personal stuff. But it's interesting
like at the same time that they had
started dating and all this stuff is
going on. He sent you two more
screenshots. I don't know if this is in
the album or not. I think this comes
from another server. But
>> holy [__] how are you getting all of
this? I'm actually kind of jealous how
much screenshots you have.
>> Oh my god. Okay, hold on. I'm out with
this.
>> I'm actually kind of jealous of of
Destiny.
Okay. Dewey food. I'm kidding. I'm
kidding.
>> Kind of kind of weird. A little weird
there. Wait,
>> this just made food shops here. True.
>> What's weird?
>> What Kellyy's saying Cher's doing, I
guess. I don't know.
>> Okay. Because he had told me she had
sent him unsolicited nudes back in like
February. So, I was baffled how they
were dating now.
>> Wait, [__] me. Oh, dude. Yes, I even
forgot about the unsolicited news point
now. Like, oh, [__]
>> Was that even a point? Are they just
pretending to know about [__]
Are they just pretending to know about
[__] I have never heard this before
now.
Never heard this before now. They're
just pretending to remember [__] to look
cool to Destiny.
[Laughter]
Listen, they're winning. Okay, they're
winning. This made their day. They're
winning.
>> Yes, because if it's true that Cherry
Dude, I I was like literally talking to
Ch. I was like pointing it out how like,
oh, usually if a guy posts like a
dickpick and sends it to someone, right,
it would be considered like completely
unwarranted and like sexual harassment
or some [__] right? Obviously boobs are
not as bad as like a dickpick or
something, but then at the same time,
it's just kind of crazy to me how like
how like if this is true, it's just so
unhinged for Cherry to do. And then
maybe
>> non-consensual cuz it's like e- rape, I
think the great would say, right? E-
rape. Isn't that the term that he loves
to use so much?
>> Some people are into that, buddy. I
don't know.
>> The infinite rape machine, right?
Um, yeah. Um, also, dude, I came up with
something. I was like, dude, because
because JTOK steps on so many rakes,
it's the infinite rake machine. Okay.
Anyway,
>> wow. Funny.
>> Keep in mind, they broke up repeatedly,
like even with the Canada trip.
>> Rabbi Gedra. Okay. All right. I don't
think he actually fed her info, but
holy, that would be some insane.
Dude, do you remember? Oh my god. Oh my
god. Do you know what?
>> I mean, it depends on the person. it. I
mean, okay, sending non-consensual nudes
is bad, but yeah, some people will [__]
with that, some people won't. It's just,
you know, whoever.
Like, there are some girls that I'm sure
would would like a non-consensual
dickpick. I'm sure they're out there,
okay? It's just like, no, I mean,
unconsensual nudes is bad, but like,
yeah, not everybody's going to react the
same to it.
If I'm sent, you know, an ugly pair of
[__] and ball, I'm probably gonna be
more opposed to that than like a nice
pair of tits or something. A risky
gamble. I don't know about Okay, don't
label it a risky gamble because that's
kind of justifying it or saying like
it's an all right tactic. Don't ask for
consent. Say like, "Hey, can I send you
a nude? Can I can I show you my naked
body or something?" Don't do it
unconsensually.
Ask for consent. Say like, "Hey, I'm
kind of feeling this right now. I'm kind
of feeling this right now. Can I show
you my [__] Can I show you my erect
penis? Do that. Do something like that.
>> The craziest fact the craziest fact was
was if it's true that Cherry showed up
in Canada without knowing where J Stoke
lived. I think I just I just
>> it's just so depressing. And I'm going
to moral [__] Okay, I'm going to moral
[__] I'm going to get soy. It's so
depressing that J-Tock can do like the
most vile [__] but just because Food
Shops is like small and they've been
like burned by [__] Queenman and all
these people, uh, they're willing to
just talk to Destiny. Zero push back,
zero criticism, zero push back, like
nothing at all. Like, [__] like this is
just so depressing to me.
It's like there there are always going
to be food shops. There are always going
to be smaller content creators who will
sacrifice moral consistency for the sake
to um
to I guess get like their their their
smidge of clout. Like this person's at
300 right now. They've grown 50 viewers
just from having, you know, Destiny on.
Why can't someone talk to Destiny? I
think you can talk to Destiny. It's just
this person has done horrific [__] and
you're giving him zero push back. You're
you're not questioning him on
everything. You you're you are
essentially glazing him. You are
referencing new leaks like, "Oh, oh, I
saw this." Even though you've never seen
it before, like, "Oh, I remember hearing
this." You've never heard it before.
You're just trying to like suck up to
this guy. It's very depressing.
Obviously, I'm biased. Okay, I'll wear
my biases on my sleeve. I don't like
Destiny.
Um, and it's not exactly the case that I
thought. Um, it's not like she Yeah. No,
she she knows exactly what's going on.
And I'm I'm not exactly like the biggest
fan of food shops either. I didn't
expect them, you know, I I would never
expect food shops to give Destiny push
back in a private call like this.
Absolutely not. I would have never
expected that. But, you know, seeing it
happen, it's very it's very just like
depressing. It's like, dude, this guy is
always going to have supporters. He's
always going to have uh his orbit. He's
always going to be able to, for lack of
a better term, uh, groom [__] content
creators into into being DGG because
he'll give them their little clout boost
for for supporting him, right?
I guess I guess the overarching the
overarching situation
uh is um
is what is depressing. Not specifically
food shops, right? Not specifically food
shops um
but just the overarching situation that
is this that is like Destiny. He can do
the work. He could kill somebody and
nothing would change. Right? I guess
that's what I'm getting at. Hopefully
I'm being articulate. Okay. Hopefully
I'm I'm explaining my position here
well. I understand my vocabulary is very
limited. I'm I'm kind of a [__] but
hopefully you guys understand what I'm
trying to get up.
>> Just I just I can't imagine that. Like
for me, I my like my mind just refuses
to process the fact that she bought a
plane ticket and then arrived in Canada
with no [__] idea where Jason lived.
>> Kelly is saying Justic saying Kelly's
lying about everything. But Kelly has
now dropped so many receipts that it's
also proved that Justic's lied about
things he said publicly. Right? Because
remember Jessica said he didn't start
dating Cherry until apparently a month
before he had her committed and then is
continuing to date her afterwards.
>> So
>> where do you lie about that? An
unconsensual nude does not mean you're
dating. Are they Are you going to push
back on that?
>> No, I I was there. I was there cuz I
remember reviewing the stream VOD where
JTOK essentially said, "Yeah, that's
right. I am back together with Cherry."
And then Kelly essentially joined in
with Jtok. And Kelly was like, "Jay dog,
I don't know if you can comprehend this
right now, but I am genuinely mad at
you. Okay, I'm not playing around. I'm
not trying to joke. I am genuinely mad
and angry at you. Okay? I think this is
very bad of you to do this." Blah, blah,
blah. Right? And then Jay stuck the
entire time was just like he had no
counter. He had no like
>> the issue, the reason why he has no
counter is because Cherry [__] hates
Kelly. And Kelly understandably doesn't
like Cherry. But you also have to keep
in mind, right, Kelly doesn't have like
much utility to use against me. Kelly
just doesn't like me, but like like we
haven't nothing's bad. But like Cherry,
right, is has accused me of recording
her without her consent and spreading
these recordings out consent. So Cherry
is like his ultimate weapon against me.
So
>> well, I don't know if I don't know if
Food Chops is above Tom. They're
definitely at more viewers, but Tom's
talked to Destiny before.
Wait, SFO. What is SFO saying? He gave a
nuanced take on Destiny and got
logistical shank.
Why is SFO watching this? What was your
nuance take? I'll DM him. I'll DM him.
What was your take? Haha. Smile. Dude,
my DMs with this guy are not looking
good. I'm coming off really desperate.
Okay, I'm coming off really desperate.
SFO, you're like, "My destiny is what
I'm getting at. Instead of trans and
Chinese, I'm fat and white. Do you
understand what I'm getting at?" Jesus.
This guy's going to look at my DMs with
him and he is he is never going to want
to talk to me. Unlucky.
Unlucky. Unlucky.
>> His loyalties have to remain with
Cherry. So, Kelly, right, keep in mind
from Kelly's perspective, she's been
loyal to Justistical from day one of
like her orbit ejection from my food.
Even when Cherry's been on her BPD like
for a month or two, Cherry has been like
solo carrying content on justical stream
for months because just cannot stream on
his own. Like I he's probably got less
than 500 viewers right now.
>> How many viewers does he have right now?
He can stream on his own.
>> No, he asked her, "Do you want this?" Or
>> was like 4 460. This is what he averages
though. Does he get more viewers when
Cherry's on? I don't know.
Maybe. I wouldn't know. I wouldn't even
know how to check that unless I'm going
through each of his [__] VODs.
>> No, no, no. He can't like it's too
boring. It's not Yeah. So, so
>> he can get Dude, you're saying that to
[__] food shops. What the [__] Food
shops is boring as [__] They don't
engage with anything. Whatever, dude.
Whatever. Calm down. Calm down. It's
okay. Not Cherry. Um, Kelly was like
solo carrying his [__] extreme
content for months and then as soon as
Cherry comes out of BPD retirement. Now
she starts making unhinged comments
about Kelly. Kelly gets pissed off about
it and then just tells Kelly to [__]
The entire time Cherry is on stream,
Jessica splitting revenue with Cherry
and he hasn't paid Kelly [__]
anything. When Kelly is literally
helping just farm Patreon subs and
everything because that's how like
that's what is like trying his best to
raise money at. Like it's just insane.
Um, yeah. Yeah. Kelly got like so [__]
over by JL here. is wild.
>> Do you know when um Jay Stuck stopped
paying Cherry?
>> I don't think he ever did stop paying
her. When anytime she's been on his
stream, he splits the revenue with her.
>> What?
No shot. What? Wait. So they
>> When is on when when Cherry is on stream
with Jessica, Jessica will split the
revenue with Cherry, but he's never
split with Kelly.
What? Dude,
>> why is it even mind-blowing? Because he
Yeah, he doesn't have that agreement
with Kelly. Is that even that
mind-blowing?
Is this even that like
calling to food shops? Uh, if food shops
wants to call me, I can't. I I guess I
don't know. I don't know what there is
to say.
What am I going to say? What am I
supposed to say to food shops? You
should have not been nice to Destiny.
They obviously like Destiny. It's going
to be like a
talk to Destiny. Uh, again, I don't even
know what I would say to Destiny.
I'd have to like write down [__] I
guess. I don't know.
I don't have like an urge to talk to any
of these people. If they want to talk to
me, I'll talk to them. I just don't like
what am I supposed to say to any of
these guys?
>> Okay, thanks for telling me then. I
Dude, I just Oh, [__] I can't believe
that's the case. What the [__] dude?
Wait, it's Wait, that's so [__] Wait,
hold on. So, he has a business
relationship with a partner that he is
dating that he also put in the psych war
that um that he accused you of abusing
and then also all this stuff went down
and stuff that he weaponizes against me
and
>> you could ask what's so mind-blowing
about the revenue sharing thing. Even
then, it's just like it's just like
these are not like [__] hard-hitting
questions. Like I could ask them that.
It's just like what is the answer
they're going to serve? Like to me from
my perspective, they're obviously just
like playing it up like, "Oh, what? You
found this out, Destiny? What the hell?"
Like what what is they're going to
answer? What is their answer really
going to do? It's just like it's like
it's like nothing, right?
Also, why is [__] Kingler in this
chat? Kingler is like Kingler's [__]
[__] by the way. This Kingler guy
is [__] [__]
This Kingler guy is actually [__]
stupid as [__]
It's obvious to us, but it puts pressure
on her and potentially exposes their
motives. I mean, maybe I'm just like
[__] gay, depressed, insecure or
whatever right now. But I just I just
can't imagine I'm in I'm like I've
debated food shops twice and they've
been put into a corner both times and
they just refuse to concede or refuse to
like [__] engage in the conversation.
So, it's just like from my perspective,
what the [__] am I going to gain from
talking to this person, especially
debating them? What the [__] am I going
to gain from debating them?
Again, I'm not opposed to it
necessarily. It's just like I just don't
have any motivation to I have no want
to. I I'm just kind of like this isn't
going to do anything. Nothing's going to
happen from this. Food Shop's audience
isn't going to care. DG's audience isn't
going to care. Like, the only people
that are going to care are like you
guys. It's like, okay. I mean, you guys
already know. It's just going to affirm
your [__] opinion, right? So, to me,
it's just like it's kind of useless.
Again, I'm not saying I'm going to run.
If they want to talk to me, sure. I just
don't know if I have the motivation to
want to talk to any of these guys.
That's my take.
>> Constantly who said she was going to
kill herself and he said he'd be her Dr.
K. Yeah.
>> I'm I wish he could have came up with a
He should have said like some other
psychologist name. I don't know.
>> Literally anything else. Yeah, literally
anything else.
>> Hannibal. He could have said Hannibal
Lectar. Weren't these guys pro Dr. K?
Why are they suddenly anti-Dr.
Dr. K, which is what caused the I mean,
whatever, whatever, whatever, whatever.
Sure.
>> And it would have been better. Actually,
maybe that would have been worse. No,
that would have been better. Like, the
thing is that, dude, at least Hannibal
Lecter is a fictional character. But the
thing is is that with Okay, that's a
real reference.
>> Anyway, Jesus.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, chat, by the way, um this isn't
actually Destiny, okay? This is a
similar um AI simulacum that I asked um
advanced AI model to generate open based
off of Destiny streams.
>> Yeah, so true, Dad.
>> Yeah. No, this isn't actually Destiny.
Okay.
>> Um I went to went home at this point.
Okay, let me go back to the original
thing. Wait, actually, let me see if you
sent me anything else,
>> guys. Actually, the person I'm talking
to is AI right now. I made them.
>> Yeah, buddy.
>> All right. Queman who is going to the
first to apologize for me down the
character judgement in regards to Jay
Stoke right but didn't like Queman sweep
hard for Joke in the beginning I forgot
it's just I don't know like I honestly
don't know
>> the different okay the misusing of the
term sweeping and obviously Destiny is
just going to agree with us cuz Destiny
doesn't like Queen whatever but sweeping
two very different things you are not
obligated to talk about something when
Quean was asked about something he would
talk about
as far as I know. Obviously, I'll take
my L if that's wrong.
But these it's just dude the misusing of
terms I found out really [__] grinds
my gears. It's like the snaking thing
and then sweeping like people calling
other people sweepers when they have not
swept. I cannot think of anything that
um that Queen is genuinely swept for.
And like both of these people don't like
Queen, so they're obviously going to go
along with this.
It's just [__] It's just [__]
that they're like letting
letting these people lie. And like dude,
SFO is in here and he's not even [__]
pushing back at all. He's just like Lol
L.
It's just Dude, I'm going to go crazy.
I'm going to go crazy. But yeah, know I
don't think Queman swept at all. This is
just [__] But they're both Watch.
Both of them are just going to like
reaffirm each other even though Quan
literally did not sweep. And there's
like no evidence of it. No evidence of
any of these claims.
>> Correspondence between Quimman and Jay
Sug. Like that has to be the most
mysterious. I I because for me I can do
50/50 on either like on whether or not
>> it wouldn't surprise me if those guys
literally like communicated on like
[__] signal on like AKA or something
or like had rotating phone numbers every
day. I think Jessica and Queen are
probably the two biggest like schemers
on everything.
>> Schemer
what? What the [__] are you? Huh? What
scheme?
What?
What the [__] Okay. I thought they was
just going to say like Yeah.
Which is so sad cuz they're such like
small people, too. It's so crazy that
they like got their fingers at so many
different things on such like pathetic
content, too.
>> You do the same content. You literally
cover the same [__]
Whatever. Whatever, dude.
>> That's insane. Um, but Feb is
referencing that initial conversation.
Hold on. I got a stupid [__]
>> Oh, you can also see more too because
Jessica was saying in the past like,
"Oh, I don't want to join uh Pixie's
case even though I know so much
information that would destroy Destiny.
I just don't want to join because I
can." Haha. Right. And now like he's
lied about [__] everything, right?
Good,
>> you know. You know,
>> well, no, he said he didn't because he
didn't want to, you know, dox himself.
You're you're
like so [__] dishonest. Holy [__]
dude.
Oh my [__] god.
And food shops just isn't going to push
back at all. I'm going to just keep
Dude, I'm [__] broken recording. I'm
broken recording.
>> Okay, let's keep going.
I think what's so interesting about your
case is that um usually in the like
you're the pattern when it comes to your
case is not the same as the pattern when
it comes to other celebrity rape cases
because when I look at other celebrity
>> Wait, what? Why? Jesus. Anyway,
>> oh no, go ahead. Other rape cases.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Because when I look at other
rape cases, right, like um any other
case, I I feel as though typically the
woman victims are like very loud and
proud about it. like they're willing to
put their name and reputation on the
line. They're willing to put all 10 toes
down on it, right? Because it shows that
they're good faith about like what
they're alleging towards the celebrity,
right? Um and
>> yeah, maybe they're ashamed that their
[__] nudes got leaked, [__] What?
Why would they want to be loud and proud
about it?
>> Okay. All right. All right. Food shops
is uh Listen, maybe I just don't
understand. Maybe I just don't
understand the hyper intelligence of of
of food shops. Maybe I just don't get
it.
>> And like it just seems to me that it's
just entirely weird that now suddenly
>> Whoa. Ellie Ellie Ellie Ellie Ellie
Ellie, no slurs. No slurs in chat. No
slurs in chat. No slurs in chat. No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Disavow.
Disavow. That is a warning. If it
happens again, I will time you out.
Don't do that. Don't do that. Don't do
that. No slurs. No slurs. Bad, bad, bad,
bad. we are uh protrans, respect
identities, all that gay [__] Okay,
come on, settle down. Settle down.
>> When it comes to your case now, it feels
like you've got this like like, oh,
we're so afraid of testing. We're so
afraid of, you know, X and Y. Um
>> Well, I mean, like the reality is one,
yeah, you're right that it's different,
but I would be I would be careful. One,
it's not a rape case. It's a um like
kind of like a revenge porn thing.
>> The weird thing is actually the
opposite. Usually people are very
secretive about their identity here
because if you go look up Jane Doe cases
that are citing this the Cardi law, it's
usually very hard to find them because
they don't want to be having their
[__] revenge porn looked up. Whereas
when Pixie sued me, she literally writes
in the complaint. If you go to
www.streamerporn.com
and search for Destiny and Pixie, you
can find videos of blah blah. It's like
Jesus Christ, why the [__] would you put
this information in a complaint? Um, and
then yeah, and then it's weird because
like they all say that they're so afraid
of me and so scared of me, but like
people like Stacia and these other
weirdos are literally talking about me
24/7 in just Discord servers. Like
doesn't seem like these people are too
afraid. Like they're literally covering
me nonfucking stop for months and months
and months.
>> Okay. Again, talking in a Discord server
and then making like public statements
disavowing or public statements saying
like this guy is a [__] freak or
whatever are very different are very
different things. talking in a Discord
server and making a public statement uh
and public disavowel are two very
different things. Two very different
things. But okay.
>> Yeah, pretty much. I I think dude I I
feel like it's also kind of crazy for
them to like talk about how much you do
like um petty doxing or something like
that because the thing is is that you
could have gone further. You could have
like also doxed some other people like
stay
>> Wait.
Okay. I got a Okay. Both both headphones
then. What? What did they just say? Huh?
>> But okay.
>> Yeah, pretty much. I I think Dude, I I
feel like it's also kind of crazy for
them to like talk about how
>> it's crazy. Hold on. Hold on. It's crazy
to for them to talk about how much you
do petty doxing.
>> Something like that. Because the thing
is is that you could have gone further.
You could have like also doxed
>> because you could have gone further.
What?
It's crazy that these people are upset
with you for doxing because you could
have gone further. You could have gone
You could have done more.
Huh?
Dude,
you're I
What?
Like they're not even they're just being
honest about it and they don't care.
They don't care that they're talking.
They don't they just don't give a [__]
that that Destiny's doxing people, I
guess. As long as he doesn't go too far
with his doxing. As long as he doesn't
go overboard with his doxing.
Epic, dude. Cool.
>> Some other people like Stasia. You could
have doxed like some other like people
who are just like smack talking you in
Jto server right now.
>> Could have docked Stacia.
I gota
>> um but like I I feel like
>> it's like whatever you targeted only
like the primary
>> okay the savior of black people doing an
nword tower in chat epic
>> also you know [__] you know what's
another thing is dude when I was I I
feel like the rhetoric has gotten so
insane on the other side because when I
was debating um this Queenman Orbiter um
I think he said that 15 million was
justified. Like I can't believe they are
willing to
defend.
>> Yeah. All these people got [__]
literally brain broken like irrelevant
too. And Wicked Supreme like yeah he
needs to be on a rape list. He needs to
be removed from society. It's like you
>> Yeah. You did a you did a sexually
exploitive crime. You probably should be
on like a a sex registry. Yeah. Are they
referencing me there or are they
referencing Perry?
Thank you for the raid, Resi. Who are
they referencing there?
Also, I I believe Okay, the f again the
first the first like thing that she
requested obviously is not the final
thing that they're going to get, right?
If they requested 50 million, they're
obviously not going to get [__] 50
million. That's ridiculous.
They're referencing fe Pepsi. Okay,
cuz I think I talked about that.
Yeah, obviously Destiny hasn't made like
50 million. He's definitely made
millions. Um,
but like in the bank right now,
like no, nowhere close. 50 million is
obviously um I think probably too much,
but yeah, like a million dollars,
a couple hundred thousand. Yeah, sure.
Like your platform is so insanely big.
Uh, this has been amplified to an insane
degree because of your actions.
Um,
yeah.
I I think I think uh uh whatever. I
think isn't the max you can even get
paid out like 200,000?
I think the max you can get paid out for
this crime is 100 200,000 or I guess are
they going through civil? I can't
remember. I can't remember. I'm not even
a [__] lawyer. I I'm not going to
talk about the [__] legal [__] I'm
not even a [__] lawyer. I I whatever
I say is like complete slob. Don't
listen to me at all. on legal [__]
>> You guys are [__] unhinged. Holy
[__] It's so crazy that have dick suck
from these people who like in any other
circumstances. And same thing with the
whole commentary community. I feel like
I'm the only person on the [__]
internet is like, "Hey, we should wait
for more evidence to come." Like I say
this with every single [__] case. And
then when my [__] drops, people like,
"Oh, nope. Rapist. Bye." And it's like,
"Okay, well paste."
>> The part I I think the part that's the
craziest is like the transcript, right?
Like the the fact that like the trans
>> the max 200k thing is BS. It was based
on some DGD talking. I think it was
based on the law.
wasn't it?
What is the max payout for a lawsuit for
revenge porn?
Uh, in fact, the law provides qualifying
victims may uh bring civil action in
federal court against the perpetrators,
may recover actual damages sustained by
the individual or liquidated damages in
the amount of $150,000
and the cost of the action, including
reasonable attorneys fees and other
litigation. He he she's not going to get
like a million dollars, right?
Obviously, I hope she gets something. I
hope she I I 1,000% hope she gets
something. Um, is a million dollars
justified? Uh,
I don't know. Yeah, like $100,000,
$200,000.
Even like $300 to $400,000 I'd be
perfectly fine with.
script refal that after.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh my god, bro. Dude, that transcript is
when I get to read that, there's no shot
that it's going to be sealed forever.
And it's like so [__] funny, dude.
Holy [__]
>> Oh my god. It It is literally like every
single time like they accuse you of like
sweeping something under the rug, I just
say, "Well, the transcript." And then
it's just like it is it is like most
definitely. Um yeah. Also, by the way,
okay, listen. Thanks for donating all
these money to, you know, whatever um
these hate messages. Thanks for the
money at the very least. Okay. But no,
I'm not going to entertain these
messages. Okay. Um but also again, I'm
talking to
>> one of the things that came up was um
hold on. I'm just recalling I'm just
recalling some things from my very very
good memory. Okay. I'm recalling um
Pixie answering questions in court. the
judge has to like interrupt. He's like,
"Wait, who sent what?" Because the case
is so weird. Like there's a part where
she's talking about like sending I guess
she sent her a ex all of our videos. I
never knew this, but apparently she she
um did and then she says this and judge
like wait, do you really think a one
lawsuit will help them at all? Destiny
already admitted fault. Nothing else
matters. I mean, in terms of like public
damage, yeah, obviously, but I I would
want him to win. Uh I would want him to
lose so that uh you know, these women
can get compensated,
right?
I'd want him to lose just so the women
can get compensated. Um, at this point,
I don't think any amount of compensation
could compensate for the amount that
it's been blown up, uh, and the amount
of people that have potentially seen
this content and stuff like that. Um,
but like any amount of compensation is
better than nothing, I think. Hey,
you're saying Steven sent all of the
videos of you guys hooking up to your
boyfriend? And she's like, "No, no, I
sent them." And he's like, "Oh, why
would you do that?" It's just like so
funny. The judge is like so confused.
Um, she tried to claim that it was like
my idea, I guess, kind of to like make
videos together, but it was like clearly
her idea. Um, and then
>> it doesn't matter if it's her idea. You
still sent them to other people without
consent.
>> Hold on. I'm trying to remember really
well.
>> And you already admitted fault. You
already said that you were in the wrong.
I'm trying to remember really really
hard what was said. Okay. I think my
lawyer says something along the lines of
like so
>> also it is incredibly reckless for him
to be discussing like legal details of
of the legal case. This is like really
[__] for him to do. In my mind this
only serves to like intimidate, but
whatever.
>> Does that impact your testimony at all
that it was Mr. Bunell's idea to make
the video or do you now realize that you
were the one that first raised the idea
of
>> I mean Benji in a perfect world? Yeah.
Um but didn't you Am I [__] Did I
just like dream this? Didn't he go on
like CNN a couple days ago? He's still
going to get debate panels. He's still
going to move up the ranks. This this
realistically is not going to hurt him.
Like, yeah, it's going to it's going to
stop a few people um it's going to stop
a few people from talking to him, you
know,
but
in the in the broad scheme of things, uh
no, nothing's going to happen.
Food shops are so proudly stupid. I
mean, yeah, it's very disappointing to
see.
Uh,
not like I had much hope for food shops,
to be clear. Uh, you know, I
did I really think if they talked to
Destiny, anything other than this would
happen. Not really, you know. So, can't
be too disappointed.
>> Making videos together and she and I
think she said something like, "What I
claimed was that he sent me Molina's
stuff." And as a response to that, I was
like, "Oh, do you want me uh do you want
to make stuff together?" Because I
thought him sending Molina stuff was
like, "Oh, yeah. Like, you know, he's
into recording stuff." And then I think
my lawyer repeated, "Does it refresh
your recollection that it was your idea
to actually suggest making a video with
Mr. Bonell?" And then I think, so she
said something like this. Okay? She
goes, "I'm trying to think how to phrase
this in a way that makes sense. If I'm
like, all right, I'll use this analogy.
If I have like a cup of water and I
drink it and I'm like, oh my god, you
know, water is really cool. I love
water. You know, water's awesome. And
you go, "Oh, hey, do you want some
water?" Because you keep, you know, you
sat here talking about water. Is it
okay? I'm not sure how to phrase this.
The way that
>> And then And then I think
like is that what she sound like?
>> Yeah, something like that. Something
Yeah, something similar. Something like
that.
>> Holy [__] bro. I can't,
>> dude. If it's if it's cooked like that,
if it's cooked, like
>> if Destiny screws up like this more
often, do you think he can uh do you
think he'll still survive? Uh, I don't
know.
>> Listen, am I the arbiter of [__]
knowledge and uh intelligence?
Obviously, [__] not. Um,
I mean, I when this first happened, I
thought he was [__] done for. I
thought he was going to lose. I thought
people were going to stop watching him.
I thought he was going to lose like a
ton of [__] connections. Uh, but that
didn't happen. So,
No, I don't think so at this point. Um,
I don't think so. Hi, JTO. Is Jtock
watching this now?
>> No, he's not.
>> Like, if it's that good, I don't like I
don't dude. [__] No wonder they she
doesn't want to release. It would be
like the biggest embarrassment she would
have undertaken in a [__] decade.
Jesus.
>> Um,
>> wait. Okay. You know,
>> don't show this.
>> Don't show this.
>> This is what I'm talking about. Do you
understand?
>> Yeah, I know. Okay. Okay. No, it's gone.
No, but the whole thing is like this.
The whole thing is like It's so [__]
wacky.
>> That's No,
>> I was so irritated when they moved to
steal this and I'm like, "Yeah, but I'm
like there's no no duh." They try to
steal it, but it's like so irritating
cuz like this is the first time we're
both under oath and we
>> You have to gigger rape to get
cancelled.
What would Destiny have to do to
unironically like lose everything? Um,
dude, honestly, I think he could
genuinely like rape someone and be fine.
I think the only thing that would like
genuinely prevent him connections is
like if he were to be arrested for
something and like put in jail, like
locked behind bars.
Um,
probably like pedophilia if you like
[__] a 13-year-old maybe. Haha.
No, obviously not like he had before
Benji, but it acting like he's lost like
anything significant, I think is a
little naive, a little wrong. I think he
still has a lot of connections. I think
he can still get up.
I think if he raped like a 13-year-old,
if he [__] a 13-year-old, I think at
that point people would stop talking to
him. I guess the the real question is
what would Destiny have to do to get
Aerodite to stop talking to him? What
would Destiny have to do to get Arodite
to stop talking to him?
Actually, would Aerodite care if Destiny
[__] a 13-year-old?
I don't know. I can't even make a
Are they talking about DK now? Someone
mentioned DK in the chat. They start
[__] raging about DK and spicy chat.
>> Speak to the judge.
>> Stephen, that's really [__] up.
>> Yeah.
>> And like everything has to be out and
like honest and it's like Yeah. But
>> oh my god.
>> Do you think Arerodite would stop
talking to Destiny if Destiny raped
Ardite? Like full on like bashed her
head against the [__] bed frame,
broken nose.
Broken nose, punctured eye,
concussion.
[Laughter]
Probably not. Probably not. I can see
her [__] staying around.
>> God, dude. Jesus Christ. Wait, hold on.
You know what? What's
>> she would say? He is misunderstood.
>> The part that bothers me, I just thought
of this. Okay. Um, so Pixie has so far
raised $53,000 on her GoFundMe. Okay.
Um, you know how I I I don't know if
Spicy Chat demands like evidence of the
receipts between Ukrainian Anna's like
purchases of her equipment or something
like that. Either way, okay, she she
provides a bunch of receipts. Okay. A
bunch of evidence that she has bought
the equipment. But
>> yeah, she has pictures of them on their
[__] thing.
>> Yeah.
>> Why does it matter what Spicy Chat
thinks? There's like 10 people that talk
there.
There's like 10 people that talk in
Spicy Chat. There's 10 people that talk
in spicy chat.
>> Dude, okay. W
>> who doesn't provide the receipts? Pixie.
I haven't seen I haven't seen any
receipts at all that she has utilized
that $52,000 in any shape way of of
using that to combat in the lawsuit or
to hire the lawyers or doing something
anything that's related to
Okay, this is like
who cares.
Is there any reason to believe she's not
using it on the [__] legal case, I
guess, is my question. Why are you just
like you're just like blindly
speculating?
Have we seen any evidence that food
shops hasn't raped a toddler? That's
what I'm just saying. I I'm just
curious. Obviously not one to one, you
know, but yeah, like is there any is
there any evidence to suggest that she
hasn't spent it on the legal case? I
guess at that point there would be room
to like speculate, right? I don't know
nothing about the Ukrainian anaches. I
don't know on that front, but like do
you have a reason to speculate?
I feel like do you have a reason to be
like bad faith I guess right
like yeah I'm willing to give her the
benefit of the doubt I don't have a
reason to believe that she would lie I
guess
>> the lawsuit I just haven't seen it and I
feel like I'm going crazy right thinking
about how like wait why is no one
questioning this why is no one
questioning that 50 more than $50,000
has essentially disappeared right um and
I and then
you know what I also think of um I also
think of how like um so they were
comparing Willie Mack to uh uh to Keles,
right? Because Keeles um you know Keles
and Kiwi Farms and you know all these
people whatever the [__] right? They
they were comparing Willy Mack to Keels,
which the the comparison doesn't even
work because again Keles was trying to
lure the doxers into doxing her. That's
number one. And number two, she has
already she has also scanned one of the
[__] is she talking about now?
her own fans for a lawsuit that she is
supposed to file but she has not shown
evidence for that she used to do a paid
vacation or something in Ireland or
something right do you remember that
anyway the point the point of the whole
why you bring this up is because it's so
funny that they thought of Keeles in
comparison to Willy Mack but they didn't
think of Keles in comparison to Pixie
who who actually like like doesn't
provide any receipts or evidence of like
the money like like being linked to the
boss so she just ran off with over
$50,000. I think that's
>> I believe people had reason to believe
that Keles didn't spend it on what she
promised to spend it on though. Is there
any reason to believe that Pixie is like
using the money for anything else? She
hasn't run off. She's still doing the
legal case. What could she possibly be
using this money on other than the legal
case? She's still doing the legal case.
Like
if she if she dropped the legal case and
ran off with the 50k. Sure. Right. Has
anyone accused Pixie of scamming? Not
that I know of. But like, is there any
evidence? No. Then what the [__] is
this? It's just like baseless
speculation.
Like, yeah, I would call her a scammer
if she just dropped the suit and then
um, you know, ran off. But she's not
doing that. She's still doing the
lawsuits. Like, yeah, naturally, the
money is probably going to the lawsuit.
This girl is not rich. Lawsuits are
expensive. I would imagine it's going to
the lawsuit.
That's [__] nuts. Okay. $50,000 can
save someone's life. Okay. So, it's like
it's just kind of insane to me that like
the more than 50k, no one's asking for
the I I just can't believe no one's
asking for the receipts except for me, I
guess. I don't know. But like
>> again, do you have like any reason to
like the the only reason you want
receipts is to like be contrarian like
for Destiny? Is there any reason to
believe that she's being dishonest about
where the money is going? She's still
doing the lawsuit. And unless she has
like this this backup cash of like
$100,000 or something, uh the money is
probably going to the lawsuit. What else
could she possibly be spending the money
on?
>> Yeah. I don't know.
>> Pretty crazy. Yep. But like it's Yeah.
The fact that she can just like do all
of this from meanwhile like these are
these are my monthly invoices. This is
what I have to deal with while she just
like takes her time like bullshitting on
the other side of everything. She's
like, "Okay,
>> did do you blow more than 200k now?"
>> Um probably maybe probably north of 300k
at this point,
>> bro. Dude, isn't the upper statue for
the punishment 200k?
>> Okay, hold on. If Destiny has spent
upwards of 300,000
and where do you think Pixie's money is
going then? Where do you think Pixie's
money is going then?
Where do you think her money is going if
Destiny spent that much? Do you think
she Okay, even if even if even if she
isn't using the money on the lawsuit,
even if she isn't using the money on the
lawsuit, she has to be spending an
insane amount of money on this lawsuit,
right? Which is probably amounting to
somewhere around 50k. So yeah, she's
basically just using the like what is
this argument? It's like, dude, I
haven't seen proof. I haven't seen proof
that that she's spent money this money
on the lawsuit. Also, I've spent 300k on
the lawsuit. Where the [__] do you think
her money's going then? The [__] are you
talking? What? This is so bizarre. These
people are brain dead. These people are
[__] brain dead. Holy [__]
>> 150.
>> 150, dude. [__] me, dude. Okay, you
know, you know what's another question I
like to ask like um Creman defenders?
Another question I like to ask them is
um how much punishment is enough for
Destiny? Is
>> um
jail time? Probably not. like a sex
registry I think is fine. And then like
yeah, probably just like the max payout
like 150k.
Like if I if I had if I had like magic
button I control anything like yeah just
pay her out like publicly apologize take
fault and you know move on. But it
doesn't seem like you're doing that. It
seems like you're like being an
incredibly malicious like freak, right?
I would I would in a perfect world just
punishment would be people around you uh
you know
uh criticizing you for your actions of
doxing and and you know abusive women
and stuff like that but obviously that's
not happening. So yeah in a realistic
world I guess just like the payout. Yeah
just pay her out. She's obviously
wronged. Pay out the 150k. Whatever.
I think that's like fair. Does he
deserve jail time? Probably not. I think
I I'm even probably being idealistic
when I say like a sex registry, but
yeah, like random gupshit woman. Um,
even then, like, does he need to be on a
a registry? If you Google this guy's
name, you figure out what he's done,
right? Um,
I can take it or leave it.
Pay out. Sure, but registry is insane.
No, it's not. It's a sex crime. Yeah,
put him on a registry. I don't care.
I don't think at this point a registry
is going to really do anything other
than like shame him. Um because like
yeah, if he meets a girl at a bar and he
and they Google his name, they're going
to be able to figure out what he's done.
So is a registry needed here for
protection of you know women like glove
[__] random bar women or or men or
whatever? Uh no, probably not.
He's not a pedo rapist. Okay. Well,
you're a [__] Yeah, I'm aware he's
not a pedophile rapist.
Other women should know he has a history
of violating consent. Yeah, I agree. I
think the best way to do that is like a
registry. But at this point, I could
take it or leave it because if you just
Google his name, you figure out what
he's done.
Yeah. Also, fence smoker, you're just
[__] You absolutely can be convict.
You can be placed on the sex registry
for revenge porn. In many places,
sharing or threatening to share revenge
porn, also called non-consensual
intimate image uh distribution is a
criminal offense, and in some
jurisdictions uh can uh a conviction can
require you to register as a sex
offender. It depends on the laws where
you live.
So yes, it is plausible that he is put
on a registry. I think it is fair to put
him on a registry for this sex crime,
especially that it is allowed. This is a
thing that can happen and has happened.
So yes, I think a I think putting him on
a sex registry is is fair. I think any
any any avenue that you can take uh for
like a random woman to be able to uh
fully consent to Destiny as in
understand uh the risks of interacting
with him sexually, i.e. being secretly
recorded. stuff like that. Any avenue to
get there, I think is fair. It's like a
fair a fair punishment of destiny. Full
payout to Pixie. Uh you know, ideally
compensator for whatever um you know,
legal fees she had.
Um
and like yeah, ideally idealistically a
registry, but again at this point if you
just Google Steven Bennell uh you'll
find out what he's done. So, you know,
if he doesn't get put on a registry,
okay, fence smoker, you're [__] The
sex registry isn't for [__] just
pedophiles or just rape. You [__]
[__] I just Google, [__]
Google. In many places, sharing or
threatening threatening to share revenge
porn uh is a criminal offense. And in
some uh jurisdictions, a conviction can
refri require you to register as a sex
offender. A sex offender is someone who
committed a sex related crime. You
[__] It does not mean just
pedophilia or just rape. You [__]
[__] Holy [__] I explained this once
and then you're already in chat all like
still [__] arguing. I explained it.
This is a thing that is possible.
[__] [__]
What is the legal criteria for revenge
porn? Okay. Are you being purposely
[__] or are you like actually just
being like is this like actually who you
are?
What is what what is going on right now?
What's going on here?
No, you've changed your argument. You've
changed your argument.
I'm saying, yeah, it would be fine if
you went on a registry. And it even is
allowed to go on a registry because if
you look at the law in some places, I
don't even know if it's in Florida. I
don't know if you can be put on a
registry for revenge born in Florida.
Let me just Google it. Let me just
Google it.
Let me see.
All right. In Florida, uh, revenge porn
is prosecuted under the does not
automatically require registration to
the sex offender registry.
Uh, registration is typically reserved
in Florida for higher or more serious
sexual offenses. However, in some cases,
prosecutors may seek registration as a
part of enhanced sentencing.
So, yeah, even in Florida, it can be a
thing that can happen. It can happen. It
is plausible that Destiny is put on the
sex registry.
Yeah. So, it's rare for a reason. Okay.
This is not not engagement.
If someone is committing sex crimes for
over 10 years, mind you, over 10 years,
Destiny has done this 12 uh with Blue
Tea and he has done it with a multitude
of women. He has secretly recorded a
multitude of women and men and then sent
those images and recordings around to
people without the knowledge of the per
of the person involved. So yes, putting
them on a sex registry allowing anybody
women and men to better understand and
better fully consent to an encounter
with Destiny, i.e. Knowing the full
repercussions,
Knowing the full repercussions of having
sex with this person, I think is There.
trying to make the claim that um that
the only people that deserve to be on
the sex registry are pedophiles and
rapists is is very reductive uh to
people who whether someone has a history
of pedophilic tendencies. Whether
someone, you know, whatever, I think
it's perfectly fine.
I think it's perfectly fine. I think
that is perfectly fair.
But again, even then, this is not a
position that I'm that I'm hardruck on.
Uh if you Google Destiny's name, you'll
figure out what he's done. So a a
registry is not required. A registry uh
registry would only serve to shame him.
So again, not firm on this belief if
he's not put on a registry.
Well, no. CP should put you on a
registry, too. Okay. You're just
not engaging with what I'm saying. Epic.
Awesome.
>> It's like W1 guy. W guy. Unless you're
genuinely this [__] then I would
say something rude that's against EOS.
>> Suicide. You have to like die because
it's basically remember e- rape. This is
e- rape,
>> right? Yeah. So, that's another question
I'll ask. And and they always have
trouble answering it. Like, like I feel
like there's no good answers for this,
period.
>> There are. Yeah. Full payout, potential
registry. I think a full payout. I think
full payout's fine.
I mean, Destiny literally offered to
like pay her for school in private,
which I think would probably be like
more than 150K if she was trying to
become like a lawyer or whatever the
[__] she was doing. It's like, yeah,
>> period. There's just no good answers for
this.
>> Groping should put you on the registry.
Yes. If you're in public sexually
assaulting women, yeah, yes. Yes. Yes.
Yeah. Yes. If you sexually assault
women, you should be put on a sex
registry. Yes.
Yes.
Uh I don't know, Benji. I know he's he
said it once. I I forget where it is.
Um he's he's responded to the whole I I
think he said he was like under duress
or something. I don't remember. It's out
there. He's he's addressed it before,
though. But yes, to clarify, Spence
Smoker, if you sexually assault women,
if you sexually assault women, then yes,
you should be put onto the sex registry.
Yes. Yes.
>> Um, and every single time the the the
the response I get is always like, "Oh,
um, $15 million." Okay, dude. You do
knew you do know the upper statue was
like 200k. I I said it was 200k at the
time. Obviously, you said it was 150k,
whatever, right? But like
>> they're delusional and they think that
she'll win like these massive like
punitive payouts.
>> Literally the only thing we disagree on
is the registry part. Yeah, but your
reasoning for disagreeing is [__]
[__] And then you tried in the chat
to say like, "Dude, but if you grope
someone, you should be put on the
registry." As if that's like
unrealistic. Like, no. Yeah, if you
sexually assault women, you should be
put on the registry.
I don't care if the sex crime is leaking
revenge porn or [__] raping a
12-year-old's [__] Okay. Yeah, it
doesn't matter. You should be put on a
registry. A sex crime is a sex crime, no
matter the severity. In order for
someone to fully consent to a sexual
encounter with you, I believe they
should have a resource that can allow
them to be fully informed on what might
happen to them if they try to have sex
with you or are in a involved
relationship with you.
What about public urination? Uh,
probably not. I disagree with that. uh
being on the sex registry. I mean, it
depends. It depends. If it's like if
you're pissing in front of someone as a
form of like exhibitionism, then yeah.
But if you're like pissing on the side
of the road and you're like really drunk
or whatever, yeah, probably not.
The problem that nobody realizes is what
first of all, like this whole world has,
dude, watching the [__] um watching
the the cope change on everything and
now everybody's just like it's so
stupid. He's going to get away with this
and blah blah. Like I can't believe
Destiny because the problem is everybody
always overplays their hand on
everything. They just get so [__]
unhinged. But like if you wanted to be
like, you know, like it's not nice, but
if we're going to be honest, right,
people are like, "Oh, if Destiny gets in
front of a jury, he's going to look
[__] horrible." Bro, like we live in
America. It's 2025. Sure. But like
people still look down on women for what
they perceive to be a slight behavior.
Like this is a girl who is trading nude
videos of like like the like the judge
even point blank asked her. I thought it
was really awkward. The judge asked her
um he was like, "Why would you allow him
to record videos of you?" Like he he
asked her that point blank. Like if
people really think that like a jury is
going to be super sympathetic to, you
know, a girl doing like there's they're
crazy. And I'm not trying to be like
mean, but like that's just the reality
is like women are [__] shamed way more
than men on this. And like it's just so
unhinged and stupid that people think
that there's some massive puditive
payout or that she could even prove like
any reputational harm here. Not to
mention the underlying statutes that
they're trying to sue for completely
undermine their case. Because they're
trying to make the argument that like if
you send any video on the internet, it
can, you know, there's a chance that
it'll leak. And the judge correctly
points out to them. He's like, "Doesn't
that mean that your client knew that
this would leak?" And they're like,
"Well, no, it's different for her for
and they don't even make a good argument
for like it's just so stupid." But
whatever.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Go back to your log reading.
I'm just I'm here in the background.
Don't mind me.
>> Okay. All right. Well, well, one last
thing I just want to say is that like
it's it's even crazier to me just mainly
because like um I feel like when I'm
arguing with all these people, I always
tell them, well, it's not even it's it's
not even the fact that I don't even
criticize you or something like that,
right? Like I criticize like, okay,
listen, you don't know anything about
me. But the thing is is that like I
criticize you all the [__] time about
this like [__]
>> You have not. I has food shops ever
criticized Destiny outside of like
you're [__] or like some some
nonfucking criticism where it's like
this is stupid. This is silly. Like, no.
I don't know. I haven't I have not seen
that. Obviously, I'll take the L, but I
I have I have never seen uh food shops
give a hard criticism against Destiny
about anything.
>> [__] thing. Okay. Explicit consent,
implicit consent, right? Like I do
believe there is a moral difference
between these two. But the thing is is
that like they don't seem to understand
that like there's a moral difference
between explicit and implicit or
consent. What? What are you talking
about? Obviously, what are you what are
you saying
>> that like they're going way beyond than
just my base criticisms and they're
going like
>> this is the issue that I have between
Okay, this is the issue that I have with
the explicit and implicit consent
argument is that there's there's a world
between these two things that's hard to
annunciate without people just like
jumping in your throat cuz you're just
looking for one thing. Okay, so for
instance, okay, so if I'm going to if
being completely and totally honest, I
don't remember the exact conversation
that I had with Pixie [__] 5 years
ago when we recorded stuff. I do know
generally what I agree to people for and
I do know generally like what people um
like how I treat people who if
somebody's like, "Oh, like I really
don't want this lady to be horrible, you
know, if anybody saw." And I'm like,
"Okay, let's just not record shit." Now,
I will say that when we had our hearing,
Pixie gave three different answers under
oath for what our agreement was, which
seems to jive with my recollection that
it was a long time ago. Yep. Pretty
[__] stupid. But um the issue I have
is that like so for instance, okay,
Pixie I so I found out in
>> Okay, fence smoker. I do not care. A sex
crime is a sex crime. I don't know what
you're not viewing about this. A sex
crime is a sex crime.
I don't care. I don't give a [__] He
did a sex crime.
I believe consent, what consent is, is
that you can fully comprehend the
repercussions of your actions. I don't
believe you can consent to Destiny if
you don't know about what he did. And I
think making it easier to know about
what he did, i.e. putting him on a
registry that's easy to find, uh, would
allow for women and men, uh, to better
fully understand the repercussions of
having sex with Destiny and what the
potential uh, outcome of that would be.
So yes,
I think a registry or a sex crime is
fine.
You're going to keep spuring. I'm going
to like time you out. This is [__]
This is such a [__] [__] take on
your part. Like yeah, it's a sex crime.
Why are we drawing weird arbitrary lines
like, "No, no, I don't think it should
be a sex crime because it's not
pedophilia and it's not rape." It's
like, "No, it's a sex crime. That's what
the sex registry is for." What is the
sex registry for? What is the sex uh
offender
registry
for?
The sex offender registry are public
databases that list individuals
convicted of sex related crimes. Wow. W
wonder what Destiny would be what what
Destiny did would be considered.
>> Court um I found out that Pixie sent all
of our videos to her ex. I didn't know
that. I had no idea. So like I didn't
give quote unquote explicit consent for
her to send those. Now you could argue
that I gave like
>> Yeah. No, of course. Yeah. I didn't I
had no idea. I didn't know because
because when we were talking in the DMs,
Pix always told me that he was like
super jealous and [__] I had no idea
she's ever [__] I figure that she he
probably won't want to see it. But now
would I say that we had implied consent?
Well, no, because I'm pretty sure when
we recorded the stuff, we talked about
like, hey, if we, you know, well, like
one of the phrases that she used is we
agreed not to send it around to people.
Basically, it's like, okay, yeah, don't
just like don't ship it around to
everybody. Don't let it leak. Um, but
like basically the idea is like, hey,
you know, like if you have partners,
whatever, that's fine. Uh, but like
yeah, make sure it doesn't leak. So,
like is that like we explicitly said
that, but it's not like an explicit ask
per person, but I don't know if I would
just call that implied, right? So, you
see there's not like a there's not like
a clean and easy way to describe that
interaction. I have never in my entire
life I have never given a woman explicit
consent to send my videos to an
individual person ever. But when we
record stuff like generally like that's
the like oh hey like you know if you
want to send it to people just make sure
it doesn't leak or whatever like that's
how it goes. And other people who have
interviewed me and talked to me told me
that a lot of the women that reached out
to them had received a lot of my
content. Um and I you know and I said
like I've never given anybody expensive
content but but but I'm not sitting here
saying that like oh they shared it
without my consent or they only had
implicit consent. I'm just saying that
like I've never had like anybody request
for me like a per video approval or a
per typically how it works. But like
that's an annoying answer to it because
it's not like a clean like explicit
implicit. I just don't like this cuz
people are rolling with the like
>> I mean I don't I don't have much to say
about the the whole implicit whatever
consent.
You admitted fault. You admitted that
you sent it without consent. So that I
mean to me that's all I need. Yeah. She
deserves a full payout,
>> you know. Oh just implied. I was like
well not really implied. I mean we have
a conversation about recording [__] you
know. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um I I guess like at some point I
was like also like maybe maybe it's just
simply because like
>> I think I think before I was like um
>> well I is in VC waiting room.
>> I don't feel so bad cuz I didn't feel so
bad about like your sex stuff being
leaked like way back then.
>> Dickers is going to talk to Destiny part
of being a content creator boy until at
some point I had to play
>> people leak all your [__]
>> Yeah. No no no no. Hold on. Hold No, no,
no, no, hold on.
>> It was just like for some reason some
kind of psychopathic version of myself.
Okay, whatever. Cuz I was so detached
from all this internet like like your
specific
>> It's Kathy. Are you joking?
Okay. I would actually like to see
Dickers talk to Destiny. If it's [__]
Kathy, that's [__] doesn't
that doesn't find Kathy funny.
She makes Destiny Spur. I don't know. It
was funny like the first couple times,
but it's just the same bit over and over
again
>> situations. I I viewed you
>> and I hate that they're laring as
[__] dickers. LAR is like I don't
know someone else. I feel like this is
going to cuck dickers from ever talking
to to Destiny cuz I I would actually
like to see that. I would like to see
that. I think Dickers is is well spoken
and could probably, you know, talk to
Destiny. I don't know. I don't know. I
don't find the I don't find the Kathy
bit funny. That's just me. Okay. If you
guys like it, it is what it is, okay? I
just think it's like overdone.
>> Like this person who's not even human,
okay? Cuz I view videos as like a
[__] whatever, right? But the thing
is is that like at some point I had my
stuff played on the stream of some my
ops, okay, in the past.
>> And then
the more
>> I don't think so, Tony. I think he tried
to schedule something.
>> The more I began to realize, well, hold
on. This actually feels kind of shitty.
sounds like yo, you know, I I don't
know. Like,
>> yeah, not to mention I have people like
literally I have like [__] Anna
Kasparian making like joke references to
my [__] revenge porn leaks and it's
like as an excuse to not debate. I was
like, "Okay, this is kind of [__]
weird, but all right." Yeah.
>> Your revenge porn leaks. The revenge
porn leak where it was a text saying
that you like to be plugged up in
public.
Is that Is that really Did Kathy
actually call in? Hold on.
Christ
>> clips and stuff.
>> There's
How does
the sitcom king deal with both of these
problems at the same time?
>> Yeah. How does he deal with it?
>> That's why he had her committed. He was
like, "Listen, [__]
>> See you in three days."
>> Oh my god.
>> He's an actual god. An actual king.
You're not calling.
>> He's like, "No, I got to ride out of my
hair for 72 hours. I go hang out with
family."
>> Do you think it will happen? Do you
think Do I think what will happen?
>> Do I think what will happen, man? What
are you referencing? What are you What
do you want, Tuna Chip? What are we
doing here?
>> I don't know. I think it's all like
unhinched and crazy. When you're a guy,
nobody gives a [__] on my end. So, um I
don't know what your ops are like or
what they give a [__] about, but yeah.
>> You know, transgender, so they probably
don't care either. Whatever. I don't
care. I mean, like like you have to you
have to
>> Destiny getting plugged up by food
shops. It's not out of the realm of
possibility. Let's put it that way.
>> Oh, their crowd is like Kiwi Farms
adjacent. They're pretty
>> Listen, I've seen I've unfortunately uh
seen food shops only fans and um
let's just say their assets they they
would need to be using a plug because
their assets are not all there. They do
not have they do not have the uh the
they do not have the the mechanisms I
guess to uh Destiny could not felch.
Let's just put it that way. Destiny
could not felch. Um the assets for that
are not there. There would need to be
some sort of plug involved. Or maybe a
strap on. Maybe a strap on. Is a is a
M2F using a strap-on affirming even if
they have a penis? Is that gender
affirming even if they have a penis? You
guys think
is using a strap on as a M2F gender
affirming in the same way that a F2M
going bald is gender affirming.
Food for thought. Food for shops.
I'll be here all night. All right.
>> Crazy about that stuff. Anyway, um
>> yeah.
>> Uh can you say Jason? Can you show me
one link where Jessica say doc this
person? Show me one link. Show me one
link. Show me one link. Show me one
link.
>> What you mean? All the times that
Quimman has literally praised Joshua
Moon, praised null and said Ky is always
right. Like on his watch off where has
he said this? Where has he said this?
Where has he said this?
And okay, why why is the why is the
mindset now that Kiwi Farms like can't
exist? Like yeah, Kiwi Farms deserves to
exist. Is doxing bad? Yeah.
Yeah.
Freeman is always saying this. I mean, I
haven't heard him talk about null. So,
if he said that, sure. I haven't seen I
haven't seen that. Maybe I've just
watched it like inconvenient times.
Destiny wanted to fund KF during the
CEO's drama. No, I know. It's like
that's what I'm saying. It's like
suddenly Kiwi Farms is like evil.
Suddenly Kiwi Farms is bad, is gross, is
disgusting,
is something to be to be to be shunned.
Docin exists. Why can't KF exist? Yeah,
true.
I don't know, man. It's just like, bro,
bro. Also, speaking of donos, food shops
just got a five. Listen, guys, $5 TTS.
Please donate, okay? We have been going
six hours. Please donate. Please donate.
Please donate.
But no, yeah, I I 10,00% as someone who
will probably be doxed. I say this as
someone who will probably be doxed. Uh
Kiwi Farms deserves to exist. It should
exist. Um this weird switch up that
people are having uh is really [__]
I don't understand why it is. Uh, and
Quimman saying uh Kiwi Farms deserves to
exist or Queman saying that he thinks
like null is funny. Um,
is like not implicit
for doxing. I I I don't know how you
could come to that conclusion
with that logic. Then Destiny [__]
funding Kiwi Farms during the Keles
thing is like insanely like almost
explicit support.
farms has the right to protect itself,
to defend itself even.
Yeah. True.
Yeah. Look like Yeah. Gossip forms like
that, whatever it may be, however severe
it may be, deserve to exist.
Um, if you if you disagree what goes on
there, I would I don't go after the
[__] site. go after like make it
illegal uh to to dox people to compile,
you know, offline information uh into
whatever. Make make doxing illegal or
something. Make make compiling that
information on a forum illegal. Don't go
after the site. Go after a [__] law.
Make a law uh and then, you know, Kiwi
Farms would have to change its to or
something, you know? Do something like
that. But don't just take down the
website. The website deserves to exist.
It has a place on the internet. I think
>> to defend Kiwi Farms against Kapples.
Did he offer to donate to their legal
fund though? So that means he supports
everything on the site. Didn't he
literally do that?
>> Is he going to respond to that? Like
yeah, that is valid criticism.
>> They're probably like they're lit. Don't
you know you have to produce literally
private chat messages of me and Joshua
Moon corresponding with one another to
plot the downfall of Destiny? I don't
know. Just
>> Nobody's saying that. What do you You're
Dude, they're just mimicking Destiny.
Like, yes, your your switch up to K on
Kiwi Farms is [__] You you did you
did offer to fund them.
He's just acting like these criticisms
are like completely insane and bonkers.
It's like, no, they they are valid. Why
is Kiwi Farms bad now, but a couple
years ago it wasn't? What changed? What
changed?
It's still the same people. They're
still doing the same [__] They're still
doing the same stuff. It's the same
website. Nothing's really changed. The
only thing that's changed is uh I guess
more people dislike you, so they talk
about you more, maybe. I don't know.
>> Ridiculous. Thanks.
>> Um, okay. Anyway, death penalty for that
alone. Who the f Why Why did Kelly? Let
me see.
Um,
Queean. Okay, so this is Quack. Wait.
Okay, so I have to assume here. I'm just
reading this again. So I have to assume
that Quack is no longer Wait, was Quack
ever Queen's? [__] me, dude. Now, now I
don't even remember
in Jade
for the five Australian hippo. Get good.
Thank you.
Holy [__]
Thank you for the dono. I'm tired as
[__] dude. Holy [__] I'm tired as [__]
>> anymore. Um, so Quack posted this and
then Quimman says, "Jay Stuck raped you
people." What the [__] Wait, when did
he send this? Wait, what?
>> Dude,
why the [__] would Queen say Jtock raped
you?
Why the [__] would he say that? Like,
dude, who cares? This is such a nothing
message. This is such a nothing message.
Who gives a [__]
>> What? Wait, is he still covering for
Jtock? That's crazy. Full screen. Oh.
Oh, sorry. My bad. Let me
>> still covering for JTock. What has Jtock
done? What has JTO done?
>> JTOK raped you people. I'm just so
confused what the context or defense J
Queen has for JTO. That's crazy. Um and
then Kelly says Jto has raped nobody
other than himself in response to Queen
over and over and over based um co
mostly
>> when they have nothing everything is
important
>> now um Destiny is I'm like hungry
>> most of his behavior over the last six
months. Okay. Jesus.
And that's the end of the album and this
album was released two to three hours
ago I guess.
Oh, link to the song in case anyone
wants it and um just so they can verify.
Not sorry, not verify. [__] me. I'm not
again. I'm not sending harassment. Okay.
I'm just saying if you want to look at
the album alone. Okay, that's it. That's
all I'm saying. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Hold on. I was also watching Chase
before this. Um
you Hold on. I'm going to screen share
for you.
>> What are you ordering? Um,
>> dude. Yeah, I can't afford takeout right
now. I literally have like I think like
30 bucks in my uh checking.
The only way I could order food is if
someone like
subscribed through Patreon.
I think it's like past that.
I'll probably make like a [__] or
just go to bed. We'll see. We'll see. If
this keeps getting interesting, we'll
keep we'll keep going live. Sure.
Give us your address. I'll think I'll
consider it. I'll consider it,
>> dude.
Uh,
okay. Let me know if you can't hear
anything. Okay.
Uh, let's see what else she said.
I didn't say she was lying about
everything she's she said. I just saw
most of the stuff today. Most of the
stuff about Cherry is just lies, right?
cuz she's actually mad at Cherry and not
me. Well, she might be mad at me now
after the comment about her boyfriend
breaking down the door or whatever or
her breaking down her boyfriend's door.
I will say I will say Cherry sending
unsolicited nudes, if that is true, is
insane. That is insane. That is insane.
Unsolicited nudes are bad even if black
women do it. Okay.
>> But she was mad at Cherry in the first
place.
>> Charles, what did the transcript say?
Oh, no. Um, he only showed me like a
picture of a cat. All right. It wasn't
anything.
>> I don't know why he's framing this as me
going after Cherry. You literally are.
What? How is she trying to say it's not
going after Cherry?
>> Dude, I've never had any personal social
media.
I like Dude, I got I I got a phone like
when I say recently, I mean like within
the last like 10 years. I never I never
had like social media. I never really
knew how to use social media even now.
Like I I I I'm like tech illiterate. I
don't know how to use this [__] I grew
up very uh sheltered, I guess, is a good
term to use.
Dude, it s like I'll I'll I'll like meet
people in real life and they're like,
"Do you have do you have Instagram?" And
I'm like, "No." "Do you have do you have
Snapchat?" "No."
I'm like, "Dude, I have a you I have a
Discord that's attached to my [__]
YouTube or my phone number basically.
Like that's you're you're out of luck,
buddy. All right. I uh I don't have much
I don't have much going for me. I'm
sorry.
>> It was Dan's cat.
>> Literally, Kelly loing out is Destiny's
proof that something happened
apparently.
>> Homeschooled. I was homeschooled for a
little bit. Yeah.
>> Does he know when these messages were
from by the way?
>> Defense is Kelly. Oh, whoops. We read
this one. You think Sunday was on
Jtock's side? You might have to read
further. Lol. But I know what kind of
person he is now. J will accuse me of
lying when he knows I am not actually a
rat [__] of a person.
Hold on.
Also, I just want to point like Jay-to
will literally just like say the valid
criticisms against himself and like a
fast sarcastic voice and and he acts
like that's all he needs to disprove
this [__] And it's like, bro, you're
you're like [__]
You're like [__] You're like
actually [__] [__]
No, that doesn't disprove anything.
>> This is Kelly saying this.
>> Moon Ray Murray just tipped $5. Unban
me, please.
>> This is just this is just an example of
why it's so hard to like tell lies.
>> Like,
how is he trying to fight with like the
woman who has like 15 different
execution traps set up in this dude's
brain? Like, why would you fight with
this? I can't I don't I can't believe
earlier. Like, I have to be so careful.
Oh, did you I don't know how long you've
watched my stream for. Did you ever
watch me when I was covering um No.
>> Okay. Did you watch me during the um my
Fedster and Pokemon drama?
>> Oh, [__] Uh uh vaguely. Vaguely. I was
in and out during
>> basically the Fed Fedme Meister leaked a
whole bunch of DMs and I was like, "Oo,
Pokemon is [__] These look really
bad." But I never really even considered
at the time that somebody could leak DMs
that could be so easily disproved by the
other side leaking. And so um you know
Pokey leaked some of her side of the
like oh these look a lot different now
leaks are actually really dumb.
>> I can't believe that Jessica was in
spicy chat telling Kelly go ahead leak
everything do your best
>> and she is and now he's like [__] why
would why the [__] would he say that?
Why wouldn't he reach out to her
privately to like just get [__] to
chill. I don't know why.
And you know what's the craziest part is
that Kelly is like a if there is such
thing as a casual manipulator, she is a
competitive manipulator. Okay? Like the
fact that like oh you dare use your own
arts against me like kind of type [__]
right? Like it's just that like I can't
believe Jayto was thinking like this is
how I'm going to outmaneuver Kelly. Like
that is so crazy.
>> Yeah. I don't even know what the [__] he
was thinking.
>> What the [__] And and you know what's
also crazy? It's probably because, you
know, we call him Teimu Teimu Destiny,
right? But like he he would um
>> You call who? Teimu Destiny.
>> Uh J Teimu Destiny because he trickle
down [__] BP Dussy, right? So like
Yeah.
>> Listen, I'm just I'm just I'm just
co-opting their language and using
against them. Okay. I may also call him
Sped, but anyway, the point is is that
like
>> is that is that like J Stoke um [__]
what the [__] was I even saying? Um,
oh yeah, the reason why he's team with
Desi is because like we make fun of his
like little behaviors because some of
his little behaviors do seem as though
like he has watched too much of you and
that seems to be why like he does
>> literally every [__] Destiny Orbiter
is that when he says like leak all the
DMs I wonder if that came from you where
you commonly send where he
>> dude he's
like stmming food shops This is
literally stemming. They're so happy.
They're so happy right now.
>> Say something like, "Oh yeah, you know,
if you have anything against me, just
leak all my DMs. Just do it. Just leave
all my DMs."
>> Dude, something about something about
SFO just like not pushing back on this
at all.
I don't know. I don't know. Is SFO pro
Destiny? Do we know the situation on
SFO? Dude, my IRL friend is a really big
fan of SFO.
My my IRL friend uh friend is a is a
massive SFO fan. Unironically, like no
joke. They they they sent me their
video. I forgot what video they sent me.
They're like, "What do you think of this
guy? Like, this guy's cool."
He tried to he tried to show me as um he
tried to show me SFO as like a Destiny
replacement. It was really funny. He
like watches every video that the guy
puts out. It's really funny. This is
like this gig chat thing, right? But I
wonder if he thought it was like a good
idea for him to do it back, but now it's
just like he thought he was him. Yeah,
>> he thought he was he thought he was
Morpheus. He thought he was like [__]
um like like like Agent Smith or some
[__] right? Cheerio or I I don't
[__] know.
>> The really funny thing is going to be
also cuz it will happen eventually. It's
going to be when um when Cherry leaks
their DMs. That's going to be like the
absolute [__] nuclear meltdown mode,
>> bro. Okay, I I I'll get it tomorrow.
Okay, tomorrow it's going to happen
anyway.
me please. Sure.
Uh, Moon Ray Murray.
Unbann
piece of information.
Oh, yeah. This is like just a blatant
lie. Like a clear
>> since it's relevant. Here's a piece of
information. Cherry flew to Canada
without telling Jay Stoke or asking his
address now. Well, I mean like he's
saying that this is a blatant lie, but
then the thing is is that this is like
hard very hard to prove in the first
place. And the thing is that even if
Cherry came out with the DMs, um, you
know, I don't think Cherry would leak
this specific part because it would
embarrass her. So, I don't think
whatever. So, obviously
leak stuff that would embarrass her. She
absolutely would do that. But also, keep
in mind that Kelly says she has a bunch
of emails before sent to Cherry. So, if
he mentioned that any of those emails,
Kelly has proof of that. So if I was
chistical, I'd be real careful about
what lies you tell here.
>> Bro, that I mean I don't think Jay
thinks that far. I think I think Jay
always just thinks like, okay, in the
moment I have to say myself in front of
my audience. But yeah,
>> in blatant lie.
>> Yeah, maybe.
>> Uh, hold on.
Do I rip this? Do I rip this content? I
like I want to go get something to eat.
I don't even know what's like
interesting that I can steal because
this is not this is not doing it.
Yeah, [__] it. All right, I'll be right
back. I'll be right back. I'm going to
go grab something to eat. I'll just let
this play. If something interesting
happens, let me know and I'll I'll run
it back. I'm gonna I'm gonna do a
Hassan. I'm going to do a Hassan. Sorry.
Sorry. I'll be right back. I'll be right
back.
That one was a lie.
God, isn't Jay STO's like voice so
[__] annoying as well? It's like so
actual [__] grading. Hold on. Someone
someone is like typing out the N word.
Okay, there you go. Okay, sorry. Um, but
yeah, it's just so [__] grading.
Gosh, it just sounds like [__] nails
against chalkboard all the time. Anyway,
sorry. I like that.
This is also just a complete lie. Just a
complete and utter lie.
Both of these two are just complete
another lies. One's easily disproven.
She's
>> He's just like, "You know what? This is
gated chat. Okay, just go through all of
them and quickly say lie, lie, lie, lie
without letting people process them
first."
>> Saying this happened at a VC, there's no
way for me to disprove that. But I I
don't know. I guess you just have to
find other people who said I thought
this at any point.
But uh this one's easy.
>> I love how he does that upward
inflection. It's like the gayest like
voice possible. I guess maybe if people
need to figure out if I lied about this,
maybe they have to be in voice.
Oh my god.
>> Well, I mean I I mean he just sounds
like he's perpetually unsure of
literally everything. I think that's
what's also so funny about
>> Yeah, but he's trying to be like he's
trying to be like smmy and snarky when
he does it. I guess maybe he's just
trying to be like that. They're going to
have to figure it out. So like every
time he does that, that's a
>> I hate to reveal this, but that is
that's it's a tell. It's a tell. when he
does that over and over and over again,
it's because he's getting super nervous.
When I know there's like information
that hasn't leaked about him and he is
like dancing around it, he always does
that. That's a huge tell when he's lying
about.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I I think another like
telling sign of Jayto is like um
typically when he's like very confident
in what he's saying, he's like typically
pretty calm, right? like like he um like
the very few times that he's been pretty
calm to mouth something, he says
something in a calm voice, but then the
times where he's like panicking and
stuff, like he does the upper inflection
like you said, but he also raises his
voice and he spurs out at Chad. It's
like you can you can tell obvious like
really obviously when when he's like
poking bullshitting around or something
when he's spuring that's because he's
lost on the main point, but he's trying
to uh drag you into the weeds and win on
a minor point. So, like for instance,
it's obvious that he lied about when he
was dating Cherry, but the thing that
he'll fight you on will be like, "Oh, I
didn't start dating her in uh January.
That's a lie." Or or no, no, he's
saying, "I didn't date her when the
accusation dropped. I didn't date her."
But it might have been like the day
after, you know, or they might have been
like talking and being romantic and
everything, but they didn't like
formally start dating until March or
something, you know, like he'll try to
like drag you down and win on a
technicality. Um Queman does this a lot,
too. They're very big on like ironing
out like these very minor facts that are
in their favor but like overall are
misleading.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And and [__] I can't think
of any examples right now, but they'll
also do like the biggest [__] cope
sessions or whatever the [__] because I
remember when um I think in the
beginning at some point I was like
watching Queen cover for JTOK because
Jay Stok was like defending Kelly Jing
when it came to Kicker Keep or something
at the time and I just remember like
seeing it and I I remember like kind of
low-key hearing like Quman's commentary
during that time and I was like, man,
this seems so like this seems very
sweepy to me. But yeah, anyway, that was
>> Oh, you mean how they have to side with
literally all of my [__] ops?
>> How they like have to side with [__]
um Ian? They have to side with [__]
Idubbbz. You know, it's killing him
inside, too. They're like they turn on
the stream [__] today. I'm like, "Oh
god, I have to defend Frogan today. Oh
god, it's so funny how
>> it's the most unhinged like [__] I I
I think it's so funny and sad at the
same time because I'm like dude, you're
really defending like like literally
every like you're defending bad Aanada.
>> Yeah,
>> you're definitely bad empanada. Why the
[__] would you do that? Like like to me
that is like so [__] insane to me.
But um but yeah, like and then they
wonder and then they wonder, oh why do
you keep on associating us with doxing?
Why do you keep doing that? Why do you
keep associ with love? Oh, anyway, it's
time for my next segment. Um, the 50
defenses of bad eanatas. Like, what the
[__] dude? But that's crazy to me.
Anyway, you know, it's just insane.
Insane. Also, Masaki, thank you so much
for the 1000 subs. I appreciate that,
buddy. Thank you so much.
>> But then, but then she also will say
that,
>> do we have access to
>> uh [__] Discord voice chat?
Apparently, he ended a stream and now
he's in his voice chat doing a massive
co- session.
>> Oh.
No, no, no, no. I don't I don't have
access. I Dude, people think, dude, is
the Yeah. I mean, like I remember when
you said on stream the other day, you
were talking about like, oh, you know, I
don't know why people think I have some
kind of like super plan thing. I just do
everything myself. I have to send every
I mean, it's kind of the same with me.
Like, the thing is that I don't have any
Skittles listening in. I don't have any
whatever. So, yeah, I don't really have
access to that sadly.
>> But,
>> you know what? I'd be totally down for
that being leaked. Okay. Listen,
recordings. All right. I'm just kidding.
Okay. All right. Well, actually, if I
disprove it, it just proves that I lied
to her directly. So, there's just no
reason to engage with this person. The
cow's out of milk.
>> I He was like, you know what killed
Queen to [__] enga agree with Idos? I
was like, bro, how hard is it to agree
and disagree with positions rather than
people? Like, yeah, I'm going to agree
with Assan when he's right. I'm going to
agree with Destiny when he's right. I'll
agree with Queen when he's right. I'll
disagree with a queen when I think he's
wrong. Agree with [__] positions.
Don't agree with people. So [__]
[__] dude. I heard him say that
while I was grabbing my little snack.
>> I sped. I soy jacked. You guys wouldn't
believe it. I did it, though.
>> And I just I just told her like, "Leak
everything you know about me right now
cuz I just I don't want to sit here and
be like,
>> when is she going to make something up?
When is she going to try to tip some
drama over by trying to leak something
about me?" So, I just said, "Kelly, leak
everything you know right now. Just say
everything you got. Empty everything you
got."
>> The really funny thing, too. God, I It's
nice seeing them fight with each other.
I feel bad saying this, but like in like
I'm I'm glad that everything kind of
like came down on um Ethan because like
if I can show a second person that has
to deal with the same stuff, it makes me
not sound like an actual skitso. But
it's funny because like watching Kelly
fight with Justicle, Kelly can can can
demonstrate to uh everybody else the
same types of attack patterns that I'm
talking about. Like I don't think that I
don't think Justicle ever said Just
never said you guys or Destiny should
attack Kelly, right? Jessica never said
that. But like look at what like look
read this like she's right.
Okay, hold on. I'm gonna show this on
screen. Let's see. Also,
you mentally deficient excuse for a
human being. I'm mad about Jesus. I'm
mad about what you said on stream
yesterday. Hold on, I'm going to show
this big screen.
Honestly, the person who said the most
[__] the most vile um [__] the worst
[__] was Kelly, and she's not around
anymore. And Destiny doesn't even get
mad about Kelly. He's not even mad at
her. He's not targeting her in any way,
right? But like that's the person who
said the most unhinched [__] about him.
That's what's funny to me is I so
clearly disingenuous just in his
criticisms of my community. That's that
he like totally gave Kelly a pass
because she doesn't like me now. If you
try to come at me for being obsessed ex
with your history and expect me not to
shoot back at you, then you're [__]
Yeah. What was your point with this
again?
>> Um she's that quote that she's reading
there. But that's what Jisle said on
stream yesterday. Just is trying to get
me to attack Kelly because doesn't like
that he's getting basically [__] from
all ends right now.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> How? What are you talking, bro?
These people are the masters of figuring
out u implicit things without explaining
how they're implied. They're they're the
masters at this. Is this is epic stuff.
>> Um Oh, two more screenshots.
I think I think it's also kind of crazy
because again I feel as though
everything that JTO does is like
projection, right? Like for example um
especially when it comes to the clout
points, right? Like he thinks that oh
yeah, Kelly didn't stay around because
there's no more clout. Meanwhile, Kelly
says like I've been in your community
since day one when you had like nobody
there. So it's like
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Anyway, um, Kelly
says,
"Why does this stupid [__] keep saying
this is easily disprovable and then
never shows any [__] proof?" True.
True. Oh, [__] me.
See, open like this one.
Everyone already thinks you're a
weirder.
>> Does food shops have like jas? Why are
Why are the rings around their eyes so
yellow?
Have they always been like this?
Like this looks super [__] yellow.
Is that racist for me to say? Am I being
racist? I don't know. Very odd. Very odd
color here.
>> Loser in a crazy relationship with
another
committed desperately sat around trying
to communicate via her husband/sister.
What
was this? Well, you Accusing
me of being a liar is not going to help
you because the truth always win. You
snibling [__] Holy [__] dude. Dude,
Kelly Kelly really pulling through.
Okay, at this rate, she might get
accepted back into DG at this rate.
>> And then the funny thing is the one
person that maybe could possibly help
Distrile
is sitting it out.
Oh yeah. Oh no.
Oh no. Dude. Oh no.
Oh no. Cherry not interested in proxy
fighting with anyone for the enjoyment
of words online. Dude, waste of dude
that's dude that's why it's like that's
why it's a matter of time isn't it? Like
before they just turn on each other.
[__] me dude. Free this Thursday. We are
excited to have you join my show. We
welcome you. Salvo pancakes. Open arms
and safe arms.
>> Salvo pancakes.
>> Now we have these like commentary freaks
trying to worm their way in as well.
Wait, hold on. I'm getting more
screenshots from somewhere else.
Spin boy. Bro, call him the [__] out for
using Kelly on his side. These two [__]
keep tossing that [__] [__] between
each other for whoever she's fighting at
the time. Just tell her to [__] off.
She's [__] Jesus. Oh, I'm giving
you more Kelly. Oh my god. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Um,
open link.
Oh dear. Jay's still calling me the
local. No.
>> Oh, she's referring to the she's
referring to the VC right now. Jessica
is watching us say hi and then he's just
basically saying that Kelly Jeene is
lying over and over and over again.
>> Yeah. Hi, J.
>> No self-awareness. Great. He's
perpetuating the idea that I'm strong
enough to break down doors, though.
What? Wait, what? I don't know where
that came from. Um,
okay. Let me open this one.
>> Bro, who kicked me from Chad's Discord?
>> What? From Spicy Chat? Why is Chud Logic
such a cuck? Oh my god. Flexing the big
connect right now. Oh, dude. Dude, that
is actually [__] Actually [__] dude.
That's actually Wait, no.
>> Why does he care? Doesn't he not like
Spicy? Why does he care she was removed?
>> I didn't even know she was removed. Why
was she removed?
No. No. I don't even know if it's like
Chud. Could it be Chud? Can it be Chud?
I don't know. I I feel like only Chud
has the authority to do a big action
like that, right? To ban Kelly. Um,
unless cuz I know some of the other
spicy mods. No way. No way.
>> Why would Chud be the only one that's
able to ban people.
He's probably [__] asleep right now.
What are you talking about?
>> Yeah, maybe it has to come from Top R.
Anyway,
Jay Stop pulling the strings in spicy
chat now. That is crazy to me. But also
mainly because Spicy Chat was literally
on Kelly's side um from all the
screenshots.
>> Yeah. No [__] Because Justical is
literally choosing the dumbest Why are
my ops so horrible,
>> dude? Like what the [__] Why would he
Why is he dating and weaponizing Cherry
against me for eight months? How could
he possibly think that?
>> How is he?
He's just like saying [__] He's just
saying [__] at this point. This is
ridiculous. He's just saying [__] He's
just saying [__] He's just saying [__]
>> This would go well for him. Not to
mention in the background, he's
sniveling and crying about being
overweight. Crying about, you know,
obligations to
>> cut is live on kick. Is he
this early? Why?
in the bio he would understand he just
recently turned
>> he's like live five hours early why for
what
>> gap between them nevertheless he can
inappropriate message I
>> oh he's going off the the pyro document
the pyro document is damning okay the
issue I I spoke about this like right at
the beginning of stream
okay the pyro do is is damning in terms
of proving he's a liar is it damning in
proving that he's a pedophile is he
damning in proving
uh or in proving that he is a groomer or
a predator. No,
you know, Mark, I I read the document
like 5 months ago.
I knew about this for a while. I told
him the document was not the right way
to go. I would just post a video.
Um but yeah, it proves that he's a liar.
It proves that he is like a a malicious
freak. Um, does it prove that he's a
pedo or predator or whatever? No. Does
it prove that he had multiple other
sexual conversations with minors and it
was not just ivory? Uh, yes.
Definitively. Yes. So, if you want to
describe that as a predator, it's on you
kind of mostly. But yeah, he uh
definitely proves that he's like a liar
is my opinion on it. Hold on. Wait, hold
on. Sorry. Other DMs.
>> Hold on. Hold on. You want to hear
something funny? So sometimes when he
streams um you can like when he gets
really excited he starts like bouncing
on his chair and you can actually hear
the [__] chair squeak and I think
it's just the funniest [__] ever. Like
you can who cares broke material has to
be what makes up that chair that Jay
Suck is bouncing on at all times. All
right. Like like it's like it's like
it's it's under immense pressure. All
right. It's like a [__] hydraulic
press. Like what Jesus happened
>> here? Here here's a um I I don't know if
I tweeted out the screenshot or not.
>> Um but if you haven't seen it, then
that's these are messages between just
and Kelly.
>> Oh, can I screen share this?
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, yeah. Obviously I can. Okay. Yeah.
J Stoke, just sad. I think I just
invested way too much, dude. No kidding,
huh? Like I kind of spent too little
time with my family to try to help
Carrie.
Dude. Oh, I don't Dude, this is so
cringy, dude. I I feel Oh god, dude.
Give me a break. And that's where the
anger comes. Dude, listen, Jay. It's
never too late to start, okay? Jesus,
they need you. I put her as a high
priority in my life after I banned her
for not respecting the time and drain
black bar was putting on me. And she
flips on me and tries to nuke me
publicly. So, I just need to probably
work on my own stuff. Oh no. That's what
everyone says,
dude. You whenever whenever someone like
goes through a breakup or something, you
know, the homie is always like, "Oh
yeah, I'm going to hit the gym. I'm go
see a
>> Yeah. You know what the sad thing is?
You know what the sad thing is? These
DMs were back in March.
>> What?
>> I'm kind of getting uninterested in
this. If this doesn't get good,
>> bro.
>> Soon.
That's crazy. I can't wait, dude. He
must have He's like He's like mentally
deteriorating at like a [__]
exponential rate. I think at this point
he might like degrade back into like a
[__] primordial amoeba or something.
>> Um and she flips on me and tries to nuke
me publicly. So, I just need to probably
work on my own stuff. It's extremely
frustrating is all. Oh, and when she had
>> kind of melted down on me, I didn't cut
her off the
>> Yes, fairy queen. We're watching it
right now. It's live happening right
now. We're uh about an hour behind. Are
they still talking?
Yeah, they're still He's still on.
They're still talking.
>> Um I still let her contact me. I never
treated her like she was insane.
>> As you would expect, Fairy Queen, as you
would expect. Uh Food Shops is giving no
push back. Uh and they are literally
just saying [__] They are literally
just saying [__] Um they're like
actually lying. It's crazy. It's epic. I
mean, again, did I expect anything less?
Not really.
Hello, food shops. True. Listen, guys.
We've been live 6 and 1/2 hours. I would
appreciate some support. All right.
about, you know, like 20 of you have not
liked the stream. Like the like the
stream. Subscribe to the channel if you
haven't. Donote to the stream. $5 TTS.
All right. Donate. Okay. If we get
donations, I will keep going. But I'm
probably going to end soon cuz I'm very
tired and this is getting very
repetitive. So, unless we get some
Oilers,
uh, don't expect the stream to go on,
you know, past the hour marks, like 30
more minutes maybe, probably sooner. or
lying about her feelings. Um, which was
in retrospect a huge mistake. I'm done
talking about it.
>> Which was in retrospect a huge mistake.
Saying that
>> like food shops is just mimicking what
Destiny's doing.
>> Huge mistake.
>> Like watch Destiny's first is going to
go. He's going to do that first and then
Food Shops is going to do it after him.
>> Done talking.
>> See, dude, they're literally just like
copying him. They're literally copying
his [__] mannerisms live in front of
him right after he does them.
She's done this multiple times. What is
going on? This is like insane levels of
skinwalking. This is crazy.
>> Was in retrospect a huge mistake saying
that he so he should have treated her
like she was insane and lying about her
feelings.
>> I don't know, man. That's pretty That's
kind of wacky. That's pretty That's kind
of a big in March. He said that in
March. Damn. What's going on? Big dog.
Big dog. Wait, what happened? What the
Oh my god. It can't be the [__] right?
It can't be the gorilla grip, dude. I
can't
>> gorilla grip.
Listen, don't in the If you guys say
stuff like that over here, you're going
to get you're going to get banned. We do
not refer to black women as gorillas.
That is a ridiculous uh you know,
reductive statement. Black women are not
gorillas.
All right? Do not refer to them as such.
This is an insanely racist comment from
food shops. We do not allow racism over
here on this stream. Do not refer to
black women as gorillas. Okay. Horrific
thing food shops just said.
Hold on. This was like a huge mistake.
I'm done talking about it. If I bring it
up again, please slap some sense into me
verbally.
>> It's so
>> Oh my god. You know what he's trying to
do?
>> Yeah. What?
>> He's trying to He's doing the thing.
Remember when I posted that thing? Uh,
don't I'm not
>> I don't know. Like what is funny about
this DM? It's just like him talking to
who he assumes is like a friend.
It's like
what about the I don't I don't know.
Maybe I'm Soy. Maybe I'm missing the
point. Maybe I don't hate Jtock enough.
Maybe I don't hate Jtock enough. I don't
know.
>> Not dating anymore. If I do it or
whatever, remind me. Oh, you don't know
that. Those are old memes. Those are
old.
>> I know. No, I know what you're talking
about. Listen,
>> I'm swearing off all women forever.
Whatever.
>> I'm swearing all women forever. Dude, he
dude literally timu literally teamu
destiny. Literally team of destiny. I'm
telling you,
>> you can't say teamu destiny when you are
literally copying his mannerisms in
front of him seconds after he does them.
But whatever. But whatever you dude, I'm
telling you, he's [__] Alibaba.
Alibaba [__] Amazon Fresh Destiny,
dude. That's what I'm telling you, dude.
It's Dude, it's actually so crazy to me.
Jesus. Um, [__] AliExpress. Yeah. Um,
this dude. Oh my I can't believe, dude.
I just like I just I just can't believe
he did all of this, dude. I just,
bro. Bro, dude, I I can't believe [__]
can corrupt such a man to this state. It
is diabolical. Um, okay. I'm going to
switch back to Wait, hold on. Let me
check if there's any other stuff that
people sent me.
Oh no. Okay, hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
I'm gonna share this with you um on
stream. Hold on,
>> dude. What? Okay. Okay. [__] Who is
still in there? Neorack. Oh, so this is
a um Kelly with a screenshot of
>> Yeah, I see it.
>> Yeah. Unable to
>> It was a silent perm ban. Damn.
Jessical. This is what they mean when
they say narrative control. Oh my god.
He must be This is why I shut her stream
off. He's probably [__] scurrying
like a little rat [__] behind the
scenes,
>> dude. I Dude, it's just so Wait, how
could you Wait, why would you throw in
your your your thing with Chase of all
people? That's [__] insane, right?
Like,
>> okay, can we can we like why the [__]
would Chud
ban
ban Kelly on behalf of Jtock? Like, what
are these people talking about? This is
only like rhetoric to to to serve like
DGG crowds.
This is like this is literally only
rhetoric to serve DG crowds because
nobody who like knows anything about
[__] Chud or anything about Jtock.
Neither of these people would give a
[__] I do not see J-Tock requesting the
ban of of of Kelly from anywhere. And I
don't see Chud giving a [__] about his
interpersonal drama with Kelly.
I who what ban would even what mod would
have even banned her? I don't know.
If I had to guess, I would assume it's
to ban her is to like prevent like DGG
people from piling into Spicy. If I had
to guess, I don't even know. I wouldn't
know.
>> Chud
did Chud actually ban her or was it
somebody else? Maybe.
>> I I would like to think that Chud isn't
this dumb. Um because he really isn't.
But the thing is is that it's just like
I Oh, you know what? I I'm just going to
guess it's a spicy mod for now. I'm just
going to assume it's a some random spicy
mod that is super um uh amiable towards
Jtock. I'm just going to assume that
right now. Okay. Anyway, why would any
of the spicy mods be amicable towards
Jtock?
Like they're literally just like they're
literally just saying [__] They're
literally just saying [__]
They're literally just saying [__] It's
It's like so bizarre. I don't get it. I
don't get it.
Holy [__]
Let me see.
I'm sure there's more people not
interested in proxy fighting. Oh, right.
I already saw that one. That was funny.
Um, okay. Okay. I'm going to go back to
Chase. I'm going to delete all these
tabs.
Dude, Cherry must be going through some
Dude, she's about to crash out. She's on
her way to [__] speed on crash out at
this.
>> I would say that the scariest person
like the person you should be the most
concerned about right now is [__]
Jessica murdering Cherry because if he
kills Cherry, then he can lie about
everything related to their
relationship. But right now, he has to
be very careful what he says cuz he
probably doesn't want to be truthful
about anything related to Cherry. But if
he lies about it and Cherry has another
BPD moment and leaks it later on. Kelly
can correct the record and Cherry can
like you know [__] up any lies that he
tells like
>> oh my god.
>> Listen listen one of them might die the
next time they have sex. Okay. So it's
okay anyway.
>> Jesus.
>> What is this for the listeners?
>> Damn.
>> Oh uh it's Kelly logs. So she said she
said that
>> saying that we are lying about it's so
funny how is transparently lying right
now. Unfortunately I can only vague
post. He's such a [__] loser. This
guy sounds like he was [__] peanut
butter trapped in his throat
permanently. He's so [__] molding
right now. Holy [__]
>> The vague post doesn't even make sense.
Like the thing is that everyone is
already pulling out all the stops and
every single possible ammunition. Like
what else do you have to like [__]
keep in your ammunition box? Like Jesus.
Um my address we're asking.
>> Don't worry. He's got crazy leaks. Okay.
He's about to destroy everybody. Okay.
>> I'm sure I'm sure the 10 other women are
ready to come forward at any time for
him. Jesus. But asking for his address
for everybody. They're all
>> defense the Queenman defense force and
everybody and Auggie and
>> dude I I don't I don't even know I don't
even know if the [__] like police
report exists dude I I was like cuz I
was debating someone okay do do you even
know if the police report exists or
something like for um what
>> I'm guessing you're probably not but you
know I guess only time will tell.
>> Yeah. Jesus.
>> Every day I wake up have a heart attack
in fear
>> that the feds are right outside my door.
Yeah, they're right out there about to
break my door down.
>> I you know, you know, one of the things
um that they debated me on was um one of
the things they said was like, "Oh, are
you sure you can't like cast just
judgment on Destiny now?" And I'm like,
"Dude, I'm just saying if if the police
felt like it was something that was
worth arresting him over, he they would
have done it already." Like they would
have
>> It's not a crime that you're arrested
for, generally speaking. But whatever.
All right. I think at this point
what Destiny did is wrong outside of the
law. You can cast judgment without the
legal [__] aspect. I I dude I'm like
okay if you guys want to keep watching
this uh you can go to their channel. I'm
probably going to end. I'm [__]
tired. We are getting no donos and I am
not uh staying up past my bedtime for
free. All right. Unlucky.
Um,
if anyone is crashing out, it's the
Miami millionaire hanging out with a
random lollycon YouTuber at 3:00 a.m.
because all his friends abandoned him
for being both sexually abusive and
spiritually hideous. True, fairy queen.
Thank you. I appreciate that.
I appreciate that. Anyway, I'm going to
end. Uh, who are we rating into?
Let me see if anyone's online.
Nobody is online other than VTubers and
I don't want to raid into a VTuber. I'm
just going to end. If you guys want to
keep watching this, um they're doing
like a [__]
watch party in Jtocks. Uh you can just
go to the stream if you want to keep
watching. Uh I'm going to bed. Um yeah,
if something comes up from this, maybe
we'll watch it tomorrow or next time I
go live, but I'm pretty sure it's just
going to continue being, you know, the
same thing.
just like proudly lying, which
is the status quo, it seems. So,
whatever. You know, it is what it is.
I'll see you guys later. Bye.